so the two big stories today happened
earlier the Trump indictment is
suspended I don't know exactly exactly
why but the grand jury was sent home
again which means there will not be any
movement this week I don't know if that
means there won't be an indictment but
starting to look like Donald Trump won
and the reason this is significant as
much as I'm kind of over talking about
to a certain degree this is the
follow-up we've been talking about it
all week we were worried that Donald
Trump would be arrested the first
president former president in history to
be arrested on some kind of criminal
charge but it's looking it looks like
Donald Trump calling it out creating a
press storm likely put pressure that
resulted in this going away I think that
if Donald Trump didn't say anything then
it likely would have happened because
there was no pushback now a bunch of
these more I don't know middle of the
road conservative types are calling
Trump a grifter over it he raised 1.5
million dollars probably more I think
Trump did the right thing the other big
news that Kerry lake has won her appeal
now the corporate press once again is
saying Kerry Lake loses most of them her
appeal and it's like what does it mean
losing most Oh you mean she filed filed
an appeal with a bunch of arguments and
they actually accepted some of it yeah
that's big signature verification is
being kicked back to the lower court for
re-review it's a it's moving forward I
don't know how far it'll get maybe the
lower court will just say screw off
because they're not gonna they're not
going to want to listen to it
but potentially if this goes back to the
lawsuit if this goes back to actually
addressing signature review issues then
something might happen perhaps they
actually have to go and review the
signatures and then start disqualifying
them I don't know for sure but we'll
talk about it and then we got a whole
bunch of crazy news about layoffs
apparently indeed is laying off people
we've got Walmart shutting down stores
and laying off people stores are no
longer carrying eggs hate to be the
bearer of bad news but that's basically
what we do here and it looks like the
economy is starting to get pretty bad so
before we get into all that head over to
timcast.com click that join us button
and become a member to support our work
directly once you do you'll get access
to uncensored members only shows which
go live Monday through Thursday at about
10 10 p.m at timcast.com
and you'll get access to our members
only Discord server if you've been a
member for at least six months or you
sign up at the 25 level you have you
will have access to the call-in portion
of the show we can only really do about
three four maybe five colons per day
because it does take like 20 minutes to
go through all those calls but it is
probably the coolest thing
that we do all day I mean it's my
favorite part of the day at this point
we just started doing it was Ian's idea
it's brilliant it's really cool to hear
from you guys when you do call in we
screen callers we try and get the best
uh questions that we can and then you're
actually on the show so become a member
and join in because I think this is the
one of the most valuable things that we
can do for you guys in terms of getting
access to the guests and us as well as
building Community but also head over to
trashhouserecords.com and pre-order our
new song bright eyes as you can see it's
not it says zero songs right here
because it comes out tonight at midnight
so if you order it now it counts towards
our next week of sales and here's why
this is important maybe you like our
music I really do appreciate it maybe
you support our cultural Endeavors I
appreciate that a whole lot as well we
have been banned by band camp for no
reason and it's probably probably just
because they don't like us politically
they do not want us getting a foothold
in cultural space as well sad news for
them we don't need them for now we're
using Amazon which is not perfect but we
do have Alternatives where we're going
to pick up more song sales other
websites that will be live this coming
week
the last three songs and yeah well
that's too bad so pre-order the song if
you want to help us Stick it to the Man
once again if you like the music that we
produce we will keep producing more with
the rollout of this song we are starting
to gear up into getting on uh getting
new artists and more artists and
expanding Beyond just the four songs
that we'll have released so far so again
trashouserecords.com
video production company that produces
content designed to reach people outside
of our tribe we want to turn new people
on to Liberty I'm also the host of
kibeon Liberty on blazetv
right on
thanks for coming I'm looking to stream
with the stream like went down for a
second for some reason welcome back oh
yeah yeah and for for the people who are
watching live stream going down has to
be on YouTube's end not ours because
everything we got going is good so we'll
just we'll just carry on yeah what was
that so it's free the people free the
people.org and yeah yeah they might have
missed your intro there just give them a
quick rundown again on that well I'm
gonna give a longer version because it's
so much go deep uh Matt Kibby president
of freed the people uh free the people
basically produces video content
designed to reach people out of our
tribe we want to turn on a new
generation to the values of Liberty and
cooperation we want to get into that
cultural space where I think most people
live and I'm also the host of kibion
Liberty on Blaze TV what was the recent
documentary you guys did uh the most
recent one well the one I was talking
about is was one about Thomas Massey
called off the grid with Thomas Massey
we made it three or four years ago and
it's about the the downtown Earth values
of someone that lives off of the land he
built his own home by hand from
materials that he found on his farm in
Kentucky he's 100 green guy because he
likes the independence of not being
dependent on the government who can flip
off the switch and and that was recently
featured in The New York Times as as an
example of this new generation of
conservative libertarian Republicans who
are reaching a people outside of our
outside of our tribe there's a lot of
disaffected uh liberals who love the
environment they want to live that green
life and Massey has a more compelling
story than that one size fits all
authoritarian we're going to force you
all to live and eat fake meat
I'm a writer for timcast.com I'm Ian
Crossland love you guys and uh I'm
serge.com let's do it let's jump into
that first store we got this one from
the Daily Mail quote they tell us to be
peaceful Trump issues another threat
until Soros back to animal Alvin Bragg
to drop the Stormy Daniels case as grand
jury is canceled for the rest of the
week and questions grow about looming
indictment Manhattan grand jury members
were told not to show up to court on
Thursday sources tell dailymail.com
prosecutors are having trouble
convincing the jury to indict Trump over
hush money payments to Stormy Daniels
Trump is expected to fly to Waco Texas
on Saturday for a campaign event
Trump's also raised 1.5 million dollars
off of it I think he's done absolutely
the right thing I think he's doing the
right thing by continually calling this
out and I think only because he called
it out are they backing down
so they don't convene the grand juries
on Friday that's what I've seen reported
which means not Monday not Tuesday not
Wednesday not Thursday every single step
of the way it's been kicked back and now
we don't even know if it's going to
happen so how does so they get a chance
they want to convince the jury but if
they can't convince the jury I think
that means that they lose the case I
don't think that means you get to keep
trying to convince them every day but is
there some legal precedent where you're
allowed to be like you don't believe me
yet all right we'll see you again
tomorrow until they break the jury and
make the jury go the way they want them
to grand juries are not prosecutions
all they're doing is trying to get an
indictment so it's a preponderance of
evidence hey here's a picture of a guy
near a crime scene he may have done it
we've got a bunch of evidence we want to
bring it to trial okay indict him and
the jury's like no that's not enough
evidence they're like okay well we'll
come back tomorrow and see if you change
your mind and if you don't change your
mind we're going to bring you back every
day until you maybe change your mind
like what is this what kind of duress is
that to put a jury under if they don't
want to do it they don't want to do it
yes
I think there's exculpatory evidence
that outright proves Donald Trump didn't
do it and they're desperately trying to
do this anyway but I think that Donald
Trump calling this out and saying
they're trying to arrest me is what
caused this to basically start breaking
apart
high level of media scrutiny political
scrutiny
Alvin Bragg is probably sweating it he
should have let her send it to to
Congress I have a feeling that come next
week it probably won't happen not to
mention I'm willing to bet when
Democrats saw the news that Trump raised
1.5 million dollars in three days they
were like dude you got to stop doing
this yeah like I know it's good for your
career and all but you're you're feeling
is his War chest I think he I think this
guy learned what every Republican
primary opponent of trump learned the
hard way in 2016 which is this this is
what Trump is good at this is
um feeding the narrative like Trump is
the headline all week long and and he's
both playing the victim and kicking this
guy's ass at the same time and raising a
bunch of money and and I think the the
call came down from somebody and said
you're helping this guy and you're
getting killed you better stop
so it's it's politics it's not a legal
thing at all it's about it's about the
narrative that they wanted to create and
this is what Trump is a master at that's
why I think he came out and said ahead
of time it was such a skillful move to
come out and say they're going to arrest
me next week because if he doesn't get
arrested his base is like cool that
sounds good if he gets arrested they're
enraged they can't believe that this
happened to him and uh the element of
surprise that we've talked about a
little bit of the perp walk photo that I
think a lot of left-leaning journalists
would have really liked to have
published it's gone right it doesn't
have the same meaning and so really
Trump has come out as the winner in this
this scenario
to the detriment of the Democrats like
they they completely miscalculated how
he would handle the situation I wonder
if it's that Alvin Bragg is this
low-level nobody you know it's like
imagine you're the CEO of this big
company and you're about to do a big
merger deal or some big buyout and then
the janitor throws a water balloon at
the other company's president you're
like what are you doing you're gonna oh
what is this like so brag is this nobody
and he's like no I want to be famous I'm
going to indict Trump and the Democratic
Leadership is like what is this guy
doing he is making Trump's base fervent
he is like riling them all up filling
his War chest and then I wonder if he
got a phone call and they were like you
need to stop see I wonder if it
absolutely happened that way yeah well I
also wonder if the New York AG Leticia
James initially was like we've got to
move forward we've been investigating
Trump for like three years at this point
you know someone has to bring charges
against him Alvin you do it and then it
all backfired she's like stop
immediately you're making us all look
bad like he's kind of being thrown to
the Wolves too and would hate to be him
right they would do that I I no probably
not this is just my crazy conspiracy
theory side it's about Justice also
yesterday we we talked about it and
Michael Cohen is apparently the one that
paid Stormy Daniels 125 Grand Trump is
from the evidence I saw yesterday there
was no evidence of trump paying her
anything so maybe there is evidence of
that that I haven't seen no there's yes
there's no evidence and what they're
doing is that Cohen paid the money and
then in the legal bills that Trump paid
is a comparable amount of money they're
like aha that proves it and it's like no
it just proves that Cohen lied and he
went to jail for it because he's a liar
that's what he does there were some
great AI per block photos of trump which
make him look badass I'll be honest
because he's like screaming and fighting
with the cops and like getting have you
seen those did you guys yeah I did but
did you see the AI photos of Obama fauci
Biden being arrested Hillary Clinton
those I got a weird feeling inside when
I saw those photos
it was like a warm fuzzy feeling uh-oh
that's the AI being like plug in the
world that you want to click away no the
one fuzzy feeling was like
you know could there exist a world where
it's like there's a picture of Obama and
he's the cops are grabbing him and
pulling him and he's like fighting and
I'm like wow it makes me so sad and at
the same time like
seen that photo knowing it's not real
it's kind of a weird warm fuzzy sadness
because you know like Obama should be in
jail he should be arrested and
criminally charged and it's never going
to happen I don't think he should what
because he was killed the kid dude but
he was president when he died I don't
care what he said okay yeah what
technically yeah would you feel that way
if you hit someone like all drunk
driving while the president
what if Obama walked out to Fifth Avenue
and just shot a kid in the face and then
it would be like well he's a president
he can do it because he's the president
like if no no murder would be a
different thing but ordering a drone
strike that collaterally kills an
American kid collaterally no no no no no
no targeted him
what did the drugs actually no you're
right I think he targeted a war criminal
son because he wanted to kill his family
what where was the country which country
was the Drone strike uh in I think it
was in it was in the Middle East uh this
was it Yemen Yemen have we ever been at
war with Yemen well the Saudis are at
war with Yemen have we ever been at War
One
have we the United States declared war
on Yemen not that I know of no okay and
what was the Target in Yemen
I don't know a civilian restaurant so
there is no circumstance where Obama is
innocent in this I don't I mean when
you're the president and you're in
control of the military and you have a
war enemy and you want to kill his
family members we are not at war with
Yemen so many civilians I agree we
haven't been a war since World War II
yes but we're not like you can make the
argument that well you know in Iraq and
Syria there's a war going on with an
eight there's an aumf the Congress
authorized these military military force
Obama was like or uh what's this uh
country we're gonna be blown up it's
Yemen Sir with them no uh what's our
Target it's a civilian restaurant blow
them up get it done like what there's
literally no circumstance where that not
as a there's that is not a capital
offense I I I I'm sorry that's worse if
Barack Obama walked out in the street
with a gun and shot a kid that is not
nearly as bad as ordering a drone strike
on a civilian restaurant using the might
of the American Military a multi-million
how much does a Hellfire missile cost to
blow up 600 Grand or something more more
Millions to blow up a bunch of civilians
and an American citizen that would be
like Obama getting a a group of military
a group of soldiers and ordering them to
open fire on a little league baseball
game or something what about dropping
Napalm on villages in Vietnam all of
that is bad dude but you don't imprison
the guy the commander no no listen we
everything that happened in Vietnam was
complete BS and yes but the commander is
not the president okay so there is there
is an issue of the banality of Evil And
if someone is ordered to drop Nepal on
civilians yeah I'm gonna be in favor of
them going to prison you do not get to
be like but my boss told me to do it and
if Barack Obama is like I'm gonna rubber
stamp blown up civilians I'm gonna be
like well then you could go to jail so
if they want to come out and complain
about Donald Trump and Stormy Daniels my
response is this WOW Donald Trump
committed this crime you think oh okay
we're gonna have to arrest him I think
he should get the maximum for this
misdemeanor yeah 11 months and 30 days
Donald Trump no no no don't Matt don't
give me that look he has to go and then
afterwards we'll send Obama Obama to
prison for life for the execution and
murder of children but what about like
you're letting a lot of politicians off
the hook because I kind of starting
their school of thought that all
politicians are criminals and
particularly all Chief Executives have
committed war crimes against humanity so
while we're arresting people and
imprisoning them let's let's grow the
list let's not shrink it who do you want
to add I we were talking about before
don't I want to ask but we were talking
about before the show and I mentioned
this and you were like I'll take that
compromise yeah like I I like Trump but
I will gladly accept him getting a few
months on a misdemeanor charge if it
means Obama gets life in prison for for
the things that he did there's there's
no excuse there's no but he was in
charge of the military dude if I ask
someone to hold my weapons for me you
know like I'm gonna put you in charge of
of the weapons in this house use it
responsibly and then it goes okay and
then he grabs and starts shooting a kid
with it I'd be like okay you're going to
jail like we're gonna we're gonna stop
you and lock you up we did not entrust
you with our military Arsenal so you
could go and blow up civilians in a
country we are not at war with
end of story it was the the son of a
terrorist so it was like a war tech it
was like a war attack it happened to be
in Yemen but that's where the kid was
like if the kid went to Jersey you know
we'll look out oh okay so you're saying
that you've probably been a guy because
he's the child and a minor child of a
terror I don't like War but I mean
that's how War functions I think what
he's doing no no it no like dude you
kill the enemy's family I mean that's a
tactic what he's saying is that Barack
Obama got the Nobel Peace Prize so stop
it yes like what about the firebombing
of Dresden in Germany was that should
they have been executed should Isaac who
was it the President Truman was he why
are you conflating active warfare with
declarations and and the world
involvement with a country is not at war
with us but Obama wanted to send a
message so he executed Amer an American
citizen by blowing up a civilian
restaurant like
there's there's no comparison what's the
war on terror okay so imagine if Barack
Obama got mad at the Mexican drug
cartels so him and his buddies got a
bunch of fully automatic rifles went to
the home of a bunch of Hispanic children
who are who are uh friends with or had
grown up with these cartel members and
started shooting a bunch of kids well
sorry that's that's the War on Drugs
Obama had no choice but start shooting
kids in the face if the if American
government went to war with the cartels
you better believe family members will
start dying
in the in the United States you are you
are making the argument that we should
not criminally prosecute Obama because
the extrajudicial assassination of an
American citizen in a country we're not
at war with is Justified because that
was the son of someone we were targeting
in a different country
I I think if you start Prosecuting
presidents for war crimes after every
every president would go to prison and
then yes and they wouldn't be able to do
their job it's like telling a cop they
can't get rough with their with the guy
they're arresting it's at some point
you've got to let the president do war
no no I mean it's not commander-in-chief
of the military what do you you just
want to end just let other people win
the war I mean what do you so I don't
know what Abdul Rahman Allah was doing
that was helping these terrorists win
any kind of War other than drinking
coffee and having to have been related
to a guy no man they sent a message to
the dad right yes that's right so yeah
it's called the war crime
look in war there there is a reason why
we have I I think war crimes are a silly
concept right because it's like if
you're at War you're trying to win but
there is a difference between tactics
and retribution you know so like if we
were to if if the United States was like
we're gonna stop Isis by any means
necessary and then they did a whole
bunch of really messed up stuff like
napalming cities and stuff I would be
mad about that I'd be like dude we need
to stop Isis but you know doing this is
is too far but I understand it's
military we're talking about Obama
dropping bombs
on civilians who we are not at war with
all that's going to do is make the war
worse like if people are at war with us
and then you send in troops to a
neighboring country and start executing
kids you are going to make war more war
and generate more enemies Barack Obama
should be in prison
I'm thinking about the Fallujah the
white phosphorus attack on Fallujah in
2003 where they they use it as an
illuminate because they were like yeah
we're going to light up the sky so we
can see our targets but really it melts
human skin so they just drop white
phosphorus all in the city of Fallujah
and just melted all these civilian skin
that was George Bush Jr oh yeah George
George Bush can go to prison he's on my
list so yes I don't know the amount of
Clinton's bombings in Bosnia I know the
clintons Bro the clintons are on our
list too and then Trump I think I think
we'll go all the way with this you keep
racking up the names giving the Drone
bombing campaign to his generals is that
not treason Donald Trump
is imperfect however he was pulling
troops out of the Middle East he had no
new Wars he was trying to get our troops
out of Syria I look at what Trump was
doing as trying to stop these things
granted he inherited a lot of it from
Obama from George W bush and that's bad
however I Look to who started it and who
was trying to stop it
Donald Trump was trying to stop it
Barack Obama was escalating it George W
Bush started it I'm not going to hold
that against Trump granted there are
some things I think Trump did that were
bad that we need accountability for I
don't know if it goes as far as saying
like Donald Trump pulled our troops was
pulling troops out of the Middle East so
he increased drone strikes to to uh to
maintain control the territory I'm like
I don't blame him for that I blame Obama
for that not that I like it or anything
but Obama was like blown up kids now
granted there is the story of the
Commando raid in Yemen which resulted in
the death of an eight-year-old American
Girl that if proven to be Trump's orders
then I believe Trump deserves prison for
that as well however that story is still
a bit of conjecture and we don't know
when it comes to abdurman al-alalaki
this is reported far and wide by like
every major media news source and the
family and you know so you take it for
what it is
all that really matters is you know what
indict them all indict them all if they
want to engage in this kind of foreign
policy but I but I gotta say man
you know I've had I've had a lot of
Libertarians and I don't know how you
feel about telling me that Trump is the
lesser of two evils and I disagree he
crossed the DMZ in North Korea with no
security detail he helped negotiate the
Abraham Accords a lot of that was Jared
Kushner I like that he was trying to get
our trips out of Syria very good he
crushed Isis very very good he set a
deadline for getting out of Afghanistan
I'm like yo this guy's doing good stuff
I will take what I can get
Barack Obama was escalating it George W
bush is starting it the clintons were
engaged in all of it it goes all the way
back I'll take what I can get with Trump
I don't know what your thoughts are yeah
I mean the question the Practical
question is I think the war on terror
has been a disaster and I'm General my
inner Ron Paul here and say we never
should have done it and we've made
things far worse and we've killed a lot
of Innocents and created lots of chaos
but the Practical question for the next
president if it's Trump or somebody else
is how do you extract us from all of
this without starting new Wars and and I
I'm willing to grant that that's a messy
process and I I would give uh Trump
credit on all of those things for mostly
moving in the right direction not always
but but mostly moving in the right
direction and you know he didn't get us
out of Afghanistan and I wish he would
have succeeded that because the way
Biden did it was was a tragic show
or I don't know if we're allowed to say
show oh yeah after 15 seconds yeah
yeah I I I almost feel like they
intentionally sabotaged Afghanistan to
guarantee their ability to reinvade
later if they want to it sure looks like
that I had there's a congressman Warren
Davidson who's been like a real hero
saying we got to get our guys out no
matter what and I asked him is this just
gross incompetence the way we got out of
Afghanistan or was it purposeful
and and he in a very political way said
I don't see how it can't have been
purposeful so that the lesson is don't
ever get out of anything ever again
because it it doesn't work and you have
to wonder why they would abandon Bagram
Air Force base without notifying
security forces in the country why they
cut all air air support Logistics
there's no way it wasn't attention why
they left all that equipment and didn't
decommission it with Nano thermite like
they didn't melt the machines before
they just left they just signed and and
they were purposely blocking private
efforts they had they had Transportation
they had people and all the state
department had to say was do it and they
blocked it Lincoln testified today that
there are still like over 100 175
Americans still there like they left
people behind on purpose like there's no
way that this wasn't intentional it gets
uh it gets worse ladies and gentlemen we
got this story from the Daily Mail
the West has brought humankind to the
brink of nuclear Armageddon with its
decision to use depleted uranium ammo in
Ukraine says Russia's U.S Envoy as it
turns out Britain is using depleted
depleted uranium tank Busters
and so Russia is basically saying this
is the doorstep of nuclear war now I
don't I don't know is is the pleated
uranium radioactive it is yeah it is
really not extremely but enough enough
of it in high enough concentrations it
happened in Iraq they shot it it's in
the dust under the sand a lot of people
were getting sick from like Gulf War
syndrome they're blaming I think it was
Gulf War syndrome I'm not sure if they
were using depleted uranium in the first
Gulf War or not but uh people were
coming back sick and they think a lot of
it's raining the British defense
Ministry confirmed on Monday that it
would provide Ukraine with
armor-piercing rounds containing
depleted uranium
is a nuclear weapon you and you can say
tongue-in-cheek hey you stupid idiot no
it's not but listen the Russian
ministers acknowledging it but consider
it nuclear armaments maybe not nuclear
weaponry as considered but they consider
it nuclear but and that's all that
matters they can now as they are
starting to do use this as justification
for the expansion into nuclear warfare
and this doesn't mean icbms because
people need to understand I think the
first thing we're going to see is
probably nuclear artillery which is
they're going to load up a Howitzer or
some kind of artillery they're going to
fire a nuclear shell with a decently
large payload it's not going to be a
Megaton bomb or anything like that but
it's going to be massively devastating
these are very very powerful weapons so
the first you they can argue nuclear war
has already started with the use of
armor-piercing depleted uranium
and then the U.S will say that's not
true nobody thinks that's what nuclear
weapons means but of course Russia and
China are going to be like this isn't
these are nuclear weapons this is
radioactive stuff yeah this says here
depleted uranium both regular uranium
and depleted uranium uh in their
immediate Decay products submit Alpha
and beta particles and a small amount of
gamma radiation that's from EC well
there you go right there radioactive
weapons so what what comes next Russia
says well if they're using nuclear
weapons we need to respond in kind then
we get lower yield nuclear artillery
massive explosions rocking Ukraine then
what the west escalates and uses
low-yield missiles I think there's also
a concern that the dust that's created
by the depleted uranium is breathed in a
lot of it's really when it's in your
body that can do a lot of damage
um what's happening is they built tanks
out of armor that are created with
depleted uranium because it's so dense
you can't pierce it with a lot of
weapons so they need to make depleted
uranium ammo in order to pierce the
depleted uranium armor and then the ammo
ends up in the dust in the dirt
underneath your feet that's the problem
I mean I gotta be honest
this picture of how it works really cool
you know this gigantic artillery shell
look at this it's basically a gigantic
cartridge like a bullet with a depleted
uranium tail fin with a Sabo around it
and then it fires Sabo disengages and
then rips through with a point it's two
times denser it's nearly twice as dense
as lead that's why they use it it's they
say it's nearly Unstoppable because of
its its density so once it gets
propelled the inertia is just too
powerful just rips through everything
I mean that sounds pretty badass to be
honest it's just horrifying yeah for a
video game right right but for real life
it's it's not great the reason they have
like the hag and the war crimes and
things because like if you annihilate a
country with depleted uranium you're
making it unlivable essentially if the
ground's peppered with depleted uranium
good good luck growing crops and raising
a family on top of that so it's like
salting Earth I mean it's it's
definitely it's a heinous War crime in
my opinion but out of desperation and
armored tanks that can't be penetrated
they've had no arguably other choice I I
I think we we may see some kind of uh I
think world war three
um I don't know how or when but I think
it for one reason because all of the oil
producing nations are teaming up China
is working these deals to do oil deals
uh trade in in one as opposed to the
dollar and the United States and NATO
will never allow that I I I I don't know
what do you think Matt I kind of feel
like military industrial complex will be
salivating at the thought of an
opportunity to go to Industrial scale
Warfare and or Beyond and the us is
going to be like we're not going to let
these countries do this we will blow
them up if we have to because we're not
going to lose yeah I think I think they
would love to have another War
regardless of the consequences for
people but one of one of the most
frustrating things about this is we're
we're escalating while we're
demilitarizing our ability to produce
energy and this I actually have friends
in Ukraine and and in in that whole area
my wife and I go go speak to free market
groups in all of these countries and and
our point was
um why aren't you guys producing energy
you're you're Banning fracking you're
you're destroying your economies and and
you're you're basically made yourself
completely dependent on your enemies
sources of energy and all of this green
stuff there's a green deal in in Europe
that that has already been implemented
this is the most destabilizing policy
that empowers really bad guys and I
happen to be a Libertarian that thinks I
think Putin is a horrible guy I think he
is a criminal for invading Ukraine but I
also think that Ukraine is incredibly
corrupt country and I think the United
States has no business in this because
if you want to protect yourself from
Russia
do something for yourself like clean up
your own country allow for the
production of energy and if you can't
produce your own energy allow for a
robust markets that'll allow you to buy
the energy you need and not wait for
Russia to shut off the pipeline
this is not rocket science they haven't
done it so Ukraine is Banning fracking
no Ukraine doesn't do that but but
Europe and Britain Germany and and the
UK and places like that well I think
it's it's because
you know when I look at the internal
conflict in the United States I can only
assume it is intentionally driven by our
enemies like the woke left I look at
what they believe and what they're
fighting for and how insane it is and
how destructive it is and how it is it
is a major component in in the victories
for China
and I'm like I kind of feel like they're
doing it on purpose like with Tick Tock
things like that they talk about the
Russian disinfo campaigns and all that
stuff and I'm like well we know China's
been hacking and attacking us with cyber
warfare for a long time I wouldn't be
surprised if a large component of the
culture war is intentionally driven not
and they did talk about this with Russia
they said it wasn't necessarily intended
to win an election it was intended to so
division in the United States I'm
willing to bet China's doing that to a
great degree Tick Tock is I watched a
video earlier where this woman was like
I am a bird I am I am a bird I am
trapped in a human body and like that's
the kind of thing that Tick Tock
promotes
so if you have people in this country
who are of sound mind saying we cannot
allow China to do the things they're
doing with the weaker Muslims
etc etc and then you're on a committee
with one other person who goes but I'm
actually a bird so I'd like to move this
here to talk about what we're going to
do about bird rights and you're going to
be like what undivided power with this
guy China the Chinese Communist Party
knows we cannot function politically if
half of our political system thinks
they're animals or weird things and
doesn't make any sense and that's where
we're being bogged we have weight
strapped to our ankles I don't see how
we win this one
I I don't know man
if the US is on the verge of civil war
or in one or if the Democratic party is
just their whole die on this hill moment
is removing the testicles of children
then it's just like okay I guess
fortunately I don't think the goal is to
win I I think it's more to coexist like
there's no real end game in diplomatic
geopolitics it's just about can we
survive together and Thrive together
that can be done but it can be done
through trade it's primarily trade who's
who I I wish that's what the world was
doing yeah no one's doing that
that is like how can we work together
against our common enemies against our
common entities or in a way that allows
me to continue doing the things I like I
think the problem is you know there are
a lot of countries that feel morally
compelled to insert themselves into
issues and say you can't live that way
or part of our Doctrine is that we have
to expand our power I mean it doesn't
have the isolationist boundaries that
maybe we would like it to if we could
just all stay within our own countries
and you know cooperate when necessary it
might be a different detail but
geopolitical geopolitical diplomacy I
think there's a bunch of Bad actors but
I don't I'm not as afraid of of Russia
and China I think their economies are a
house of cards as well and my argument
is if we would get our house in order if
our allies would get our house in order
we would not be vulnerable to their
Shenanigans because they don't have the
resources to do what they do and I could
you know quote Michael malice's new
white pill book and pointing out that
that top-down systems collapse yeah
um well I I agree but that's why I'm
saying I think the internal conflict is
the problem we're facing right if we
can't but it's on us right we got to fix
it
well not just at this table yes but
Americans got to get their act together
but but I but I feel like that's the
attack they're living against us making
sure we can like Tick Tock is a huge
component right now you've got the
Democrats trying to preserve it and the
Republicans are barely doing anything
about it they don't even know what the
argument is yeah I think Banning it's
not right at first because then it would
lead to someone Banning Twitter and you
don't want to start Banning companies
from the states I mean free the software
code if you want to see what they're
doing and what the algorithm is doing
Fair Point
it's got to be like an and Elon might
save us and I don't I'd hate to put all
of our eggs in in one Billionaire's
basket but the solution to tick tock is
is an alternative that's not nuts that's
not manipulative that allows the things
we like speech and and argument and all
the things that America has built on as
opposed to that crazy manipulation and
the problem has been is that that these
Tech platforms have been centralized and
and basically speech has been dictated
by the FBI and CIA who are you going to
vote for in 2024
I don't know yet would you vote for
Trump I'm not saying like you should I'm
just asking like would you consider um
you know I was going to until he screwed
up locked down so badly I don't think I
can forgive that that's a good point man
uh I'm I'm pretty much for Trump right
now we'll see what changes DeSantis is I
feel like it's shown to be a big letdown
I would I would prefer Dave Smith you
know if like if someone said name a
person and they'll be president I'll go
Dave Smith assuming he wants to be
hasn't announced yet in in all practical
reality you know I probably end up
voting for Trump what do you think Rama
Swami
um I I like a lot of what he's doing the
ESD stuff is fantastic I don't I don't
and maybe I'm agreeing with you on this
I don't think you cut off trade with
China I think you outperformed China
and and he wants to he wants to isolate
our enemies through through state power
and I want to isolate our enemies from
outperforming them
and but I think he's he's quite
interesting and and quite provocative in
a lot of ways he's probably doing what
Dave wants to do which is change the
conversation
um and this is a big debate within the
libertarian party are we running to win
are we running to change the narrative
so that we can actually talk about some
of these things that the two parties
never talk about and I think I think
both but you got to build right so
obviously with the libertarian party you
got a lot of buildings going to happen
there's a percentage threshold that's
got to be met which means you've got to
be serious contenders but during in the
meantime the victories you get is
changing the conversation yeah so you
know what do we got to do to get to a
point where Dave Smith's on a debate
stage with Biden and Trump that would be
tremendous it may be fantastic they're
never going to let them on the stage
they keep changing the rules if he gets
closer they're just going to say you
know what you need 20 of the polls to be
on the stage but the point is with with
all of these platforms
um you know how many times do we have to
point out that Joe Rogan is bigger than
all three networks right before election
combined and point out that if we want
to have that conversation outside of
corporate media we can do that now yeah
and I also think that if Joe Rogan ran
for president he'd probably win he'd
probably beat them both I'd vote for him
now see I would vote for Joe I think a
lot of people would because he's like
you listen to him and he's talking about
cultural issues which the right agrees
with but he's still somewhat of a
moderate Lefty kind of guy so you gotta
get you kind of get a compromise but
he's just so popular yeah I'm not saying
he's going to run or he should run I'm
just saying that kind of personal
connection and and and and gravitas is
what you need I'm I'm I'm thinking Trump
I think Trump's got a lot of bad about
him but I view him as a slight net
positive most land foreign policy I
don't completely blame him for the
lockdowns I somewhat blame him for the
lockdowns I think he surrounded himself
with really bad people I'm also thinking
now
you know what man
I'm willing to get him in the next four
years if we can see more of that foreign
policy if it's more of secure our
borders bring jobs back here and get our
troops out of these other countries make
NATO pay its fair share all right well
you know then I'll take what we get
domestically but I think the economy
will be good and I think he'll do a
better job well here's here's the thing
like as you continue to dig into the
sources of gain a function uh
experiments and all that crazy Mad
Science that fauci and a niaid was doing
that's actually a biosecurity program
and there's a reason I suspect why Rand
Paul has switched to the homeland
security committee because if you want
to get to the bottom of covid and you
want to get to the bottom of gain of
function and you want to find out
whether or not American taxpayers
actually financed the creation of a
virus that created so much Global
disruption you got to go after the
National Security State this is not the
healthcare industrial complex it's
National Security so these things are
very much related so who whoever is
going to be the next president is going
to have to take on that and this is some
place where Trump failed let's jump to
this story from the post-millennial
breaking Arizona Supreme Court revives
Kerry Lake claim on signature
verification so uh we'll I'll give you
the simple version
Gary Lake filed numerous claims
they were dismissed by a lower court
Kerry Lake appealed and one very
important component one of the most
important made it through now the
corporate press is saying Kerry Lake
mostly loses appeal
if you're filing a lawsuit like this you
don't just say here's my one complaint
you get as many as you can and throw
them all out there scatter shot and then
see which ones stick and Kerry Lake got
one signature verification when the the
the the argument is uh not just in Kerry
Lake's case but in Trump as well the
argument is too many signatures got
accepted that should not have that many
of these probably didn't match but they
were letting them through anyway when
Kerry Lake sued they said this is a
procedure question and you should have
sued before the election well now the
Appellate Court a supreme court has said
no how would she Sue unless there was
something done that she can sue over go
back and redo this for all we know the
lower court just kicks it out again
but it's entirely possible that they're
forced to take it up the the issue with
Kerry Lake and with any anyone involved
in this is that every single person in
politics save like
I don't know five ten people okay to be
fair maybe 50. uh they're cowards
they're all cowards I'm I've I've been
uh I feel like DeSantis is a letdown I
feel like he is too weak Carrie lake is
strong Trump is strong I like that there
are a decent number of strong people in
Congress Matt Gates standing up to Kevin
McCarthy was absolutely fantastic
Marjory Taylor green Lauren bobert
despite the fact Margaret Taylor green
was in favor of Kevin McCarthy she's
stood up on a lot of issues but I look
at these these these court cases and
these judges and everyone's just like oh
man I don't want to do this I don't want
to be involved so what I guess I would
say is you know aside from this story I
feel like a big thing that's being
revealed right now is just how cowardly
so much of our society and and
government is how many individuals are
probably why people voted for Trump
probably why people like Carrie Lake
they want someone who's finally just
going to stand up and say screw off
by the way cowardice and politics is not
a new phenomenon oh yeah but but I but I
feel like it's it's more widespread and
and culturally ingrained at this point
yeah like I I maybe I'm just wrong but I
kind of feel like if you go back 100
years you find most people weren't
cowardly although they were cowards
maybe it's more exposed because I think
I think you know we We complain about
all the downsides of social media I
think one of the powerful things that
happens is that you realize that most
politicians are telling you what you
want to hear without ever saying
anything and you can dig a little bit
deeper now and you realize that they're
empty suits so when we see someone who
appears to be saying what they actually
think and I think Carrie lake is
absolutely one of those people that in
and of itself regardless of what she's
saying is appealing to people because
she's actually speaking what she thinks
and she's not attractive and she's not
dropping it I mean it would have been
easy for her to say like this is corrupt
and terrible and then quietly Fade Into
the background right I mean she must be
spending tons of money on this legal
battle and yet she thinks it's worth it
she's standing by what she said that she
needs to stand up for Arizona's voting
integrity and so she's going to push it
for as long as she can and I I think
there is something refreshing about that
right it's it's very different than
someone saying like this was stolen from
me or this was unfair and then kind of
doing nothing I think a lot of Voters
are very sick of the inaction the fact
that they don't fall through with
anything yeah are you saying no it's
kind of telling that when you search
Kerry Lake you see a host of Articles
like robots she mostly loses I think
that's the phrase every article says the
same thing that tells me that she
probably accomplished something yep
because how do you mostly lose if your
goal is to get an argument in they're
like well she mostly lost it's like is
the lawsuit moving forward yes so she
didn't lose well she lost a lot of them
but the lawsuit is moving forward it's
like okay well that sounds like her loss
is moving forward firstly rejected yeah
yeah AP has uh Arizona Court declines
most of lakes appeal over governor race
and it's like but they took something
you're trying to frame it as you know
she's this crazy wacko don't but don't
worry she's being subdued and really you
know the issues that matter and the ones
that could make a difference are are
being moved forward I think a lot of the
cowardice and politics comes from people
being able to communicate from behind a
keyboard and a computer in a locked room
like a lot of stuff people say to each
other in social media they would never
say to each other and face to face I I
look man the DeSantis response to the
Trump indictment stuff was like getting
a bucket of water splashed in the face I
don't care a lot of people are like you
know DeSantis said I don't know what
goes into paying a porn star hush money
or whatever
I don't care that he said that I care
about the fact that he said I'm not
getting involved in this instead of
saying Fu instead of just telling
telling these these lunatics to shove to
screw themselves he probably figures
Trump's pissed off so many people and
he's got no chance at winning and if he
gets involved and gets on his side he'll
just be lumped into that no chance at
winning but I mean he's not wrong that
Trump has pissed off way more people
than he needed to but it does but he
could have said look it's not about
Donald Trump you don't have to like the
guy I've got my differences with him he
calls me a meatball but the idea that a
six-year-old misdemeanor would warrant
extradition from my state is laughable
so do not even try it and he's like come
on where the ball's at just you know I
just don't see it that's what he should
have done yeah it would take him from
being just this suit that's sort of
Towing the line trying to to pick up
both sides you know people who are for
Trump and people who are against him and
give given him a personality right like
he's not willing to take that risk and
that's where you get this fear that he's
becoming like a politician yes and and
who is he trying to win over with this
right the idea is that well a lot of
people don't like Trump and he could win
the never Trump or Republicans dude all
of the parental rights and education
stuff that he's done he's they're lying
about it saying he's Banning books the
Lincoln Project's calling him awful and
evil there's nothing to be gained from
not like from going the route he's going
it may just be simple
I don't know if he intentionally was
trying to avoid being defensive of trump
the fact is he does not have it within
him to be defensive of hard-line
principles in that way so what I when I
see DeSantis I see a guy who you know
early on he's got this policy
accomplishments he's a great Governor I
still think that's true and so you
believe that here's a guy who gets it
and now what you see over the past few
months is here's a guy who's vanilla
pudding who was given the correct script
he's given the proper Playbook he said I
will execute because I can understand
people like this but then when it comes
time to stand in front of the Flames he
goes too much for me there buddy he
doesn't seem like the guy who sent
illegal immigrants to Martha's Vineyard
anymore I don't know that's a good point
I think that's too far I think it was a
tactical mistake and and I think he
cannot recovered from it oh you think
that that the Trump statement stuff yeah
yeah I think the issue though is like
the Martha's Vineyard thing was was
masterfully done and that's the kind of
stuff you want to see
but I kind of i i i half agree with you
I think there's an opportunity for him
to come back and and have that strong
voice but I kind of do feel like this
was a bit revealing and it's not so much
about can he recover from it so much so
as we've learned a little bit about him
but but we'll see we'll see he did a
show with Glenn Beck that was pretty
enlightening I don't know if you guys
saw that it's worth watching I only saw
it so far about 10 minutes of it in fact
I'm not realizing I should watch the
entire thing because it was like oh I
see the humanity in this guy now he's a
tactical guy he's like a Jag he was a
Navy lawyer Jack guy and uh he knows
when to speak when not to speak when to
let your enemy if your enemy's making a
mistake don't stop him that's probably
what he's thinking with Trump right now
he's like dude this guy's foot in his
mouth he deserves this he paid off a
prostitute that he had sex with while he
was married and running for president
like let him burn let him let him let
him deal with it I'm not getting
involved in this crap
uh he wants to win the presidency man if
if DeSantis is the nominee he's got my
vote I like the guy I think he's I think
he's doing really well I think he's a
great Governor I think he'll be a great
leader and I think he's substantially
better than anything anyone else has to
offer
but I understand why people like Trump
because Trump you know you know this is
the thing I said before that descendants
might be a good VP is because DeSantis
has what Trump doesn't Trump has what
DeSantis doesn't Trump has that like
boastful arrogance about him he is that
guy who's going to be like don't you try
it don't come at me it's not happening
and the sentence is a guy who's going to
be like here's what the people actually
want here's me telling off the the you
know the the lockdowns and actually
like solving these problems properly
Trump's got the attitude DeSantis has
the plan yeah I can respect that I think
it's it's tough to say what would have
happened should it whatever but I think
if DeSantis had been president when Cove
struck that he wouldn't have let fauci
run the show he would have run the show
I don't know man he doesn't I mean he's
like he knows how to use the system he
he used his um state of emergency in
Florida and he held it open so that he
could reposition funds to make sure that
schools couldn't close down so it's like
yeah he knew that this coveted crap was
an emergency and it was making kids get
masked when they were two and three so
he's like no the emergency is that kids
are getting massed up at four years old
I'm not gonna let that happen to kids
well that that's that's an interesting
question when it comes to actual policy
is Trump the kind of guy who's going to
drop the hammer or is DeSantis DeSantis
is the guy who sent a bunch of migrants
to Martha's Vineyard as a powerful
statement Trump's the guy who refused to
fire fauci because he was scared of
political backlash so it's tough I like
the Navy lawyer I'm gonna I like the
experience I like having a lawyer in
presidency Obama was a lawyer for better
or worse you know how to game the system
lawyers I mean the conversation with uh
Glenn Beck and DeSantis I I did watch it
and that's that's where DeSantis wants
to be but he's struggling with
um you know how does he engage Trump
because he watched everybody get chewed
up and spit out when you when you take
on Trump uh playing on Trump's Turf
Trump's going to kill you so he's this
this this episode that we're talking
about DeSantis is like do I engage do I
disengage what do I do with this because
I know what happens to everybody that
goes toe-to-toe with Trump in terms of
uh uh you know a pissing match he says
that on the show he talks about that no
no but they're putting words in his
mouth he's never going to say that out
loud but that's that's kind of what I'm
saying is
if it's not going to be Trump it's got
to be someone who can easily go
toe-to-toe Trump you know what I mean
it shouldn't be hard to look Donald
Trump gets on stage and he calls you
names
and then you look at how the rest of the
GOP handled in 2016 and it was hilarious
they could not handle they didn't know
what to do
it's funny I'm like you need somebody
who can actually stand with stand
toe-to-toe with Trump and fire back in
the same way I I don't know who could
possibly do it to be fair the Democrats
don't have one either I mean there is no
one politically in America I mean unless
the Libertarians are Fielding someone I
don't know about there's no one who
could take on Trump it's coming okay
there's also a question of is Trump
still 2016 Trump we're starting to see a
little bit of it but a lot of people as
core fan base that they were let down by
his his announcement speech does he have
the same level of energy has he been
toned down is he going to be that
fireball should he be some people have
argued he's got to approach this
differently as a former president
because before I think you know who's
that was it Dave Chappelle he was like
first he was saying like hey look man I
know what they're doing because because
I used to do it let me in there then he
gets in there does same thing yeah he
came out of the house right and said
they're cheating you and then he went
back into the house so the question is
should he run as The Outsider again
considering the fact he was President
for four years or does he now need to be
the let me finish the job president and
and act differently Patrick Bet David
made that observation also I think
you're right I don't think that the the
old tactic of like I'm the outsider
isn't where he's not the outside he's
the front runner so he needs to play
like I'm already the winner and when I
win again this is how I'm going to
change the world uh unless I see a
mission and a meaning to it I have no
interest in like playing Party politics
or identity yeah not not to be one note
Johnny I still think that the lockdowns
and his his Relentless advocacy for
vaccines as the thing that he did I
think that's his Achilles heel and I
think as this goes and all of the
economic damage and all of the damage
caused particularly to Young People by
vaccines becomes more apparent
Trump owns that he proudly owns it and I
don't know what he does about that the
older it
you wouldn't have any advice for him
like if you were on his campaign you
wouldn't know how to spend that message
or there's nothing he could do to sort
of well counterbalance that he still
brags about about how he personally made
the vaccine happen that's not a good
idea I don't think so but he thinks it's
a good idea I feel like if he did it
it's a good idea that's everything he
does is a good idea he doesn't want to
be like you know I was wrong or whatever
yeah so fair points not firing fouchy
supporting the lockdowns he's the guy
who did the the 15 days I saw the spread
that was that was on him so and DeSantis
isn't that guy so that's why I'm saying
like Trump has the attitude but then
there's a question of is he going to
step up this time see what he did wrong
and fix it or should we just be like we
got a real opportunity we got a real we
got an opportunity to send us defied
Federal mandate like the national the
largest strongest government in uh in
world history he said no and he did his
thing the way he wanted it done as a
governor which is his just right and I
think we do the same thing as president
against ESG I don't think he would let
the international banking cartel own the
United States but is it worth having
four more years of trump because if
Trump doesn't get elected this year I
mean he is older like it's unlikely that
he'll seek the presidency I mean maybe
he will I don't know I can't he does
have fun but then you could have four
years of trump and then theoretically
eight years of DeSantis or you could
start to Santa's presidential term now
and never have Trump again I don't think
we have time to waste I think it's the
best now or or we all die kind of
situation and for you
yeah far superior to Trump if I had to
pick between the two I have other I
think Vivek Rama Swami is far superior
to all of them I agree with that but I
don't see him winning I want to support
him so he does if we have that kind of
influence I mean let's make it happen
this is the crazy thing like most people
will identify various people as probably
more capable or better for for a variety
of reasons but just not capable of
winning and that's the reality so I
don't know if that's that's not the same
thing as lesser of two evils I think
Trump is a good option I genuinely need
you I thank Vivek probably better uh for
a lot of reasons but maybe
you know we have to ask ourselves what
is it we actually want from the
president what do we want the president
to do do we want someone to set policy
is that it then Ron DeSantis will go in
and I'll be like here's my agenda but
does that guarantee the agenda is going
to happen well it's more of a
congressional thing do we want power
arrogance strong man that's Trump
Trump's going to push people around but
if he's got bad policy and he's got bad
people because Personnel is policy
it's not going to be a good thing is it
I want a diplomat but I don't want
someone that gets walked over I just you
know you know what it is for me that
always makes me default back to Trump is
the foreign policy stuff is
like the foreign policy that he was
engaged in is the best foreign policy
I've ever seen from any president in my
life domestic policy was horrid like
what it just divided the country he
would tweet about far leftists like what
you're supposed to unify the country bro
you'll bring them together if you don't
like the way they're behaving give them
something to live for I don't know if I
care about the tweets and the like you
know tweets God or or just just to put
it out there or we could vote for Dave
Smith and we could finally put Barack
Obama in jail
Dave Smith quality they're talking about
breaking up like the Department of
Education and breaking up the FBI I mean
they're talking about similar things
like scaling down the government yeah
he's got a pretty bold message I have a
naive question is he running as a
Republican Vivek yeah yeah okay is Dave
Smith gonna campaign on lock him up lock
him up lock him up I I think after this
episode yes 100 I mean Dave's listening
taking notes
you know it's it's a scary thought to
arrest a former president but there's a
challenge of a legitimate question do we
ignore the actual crimes committed in
our name because I'm offended by it yeah
and just like arrest them all I do I do
I'm I'm sort of joking about a sitting
president arresting former presidents
that feels a little bit Banana Republic
to me I'd love that there was
um a more objective standard of justice
but our point stands these guys
committed crimes and we shouldn't just
sweep it under the rug I want to clarify
too about Trump I said his horrible
domestic policy the tweets the division
but also the covet stuff man that just
like hands off let the dog bite kind of
thing with that she just let him go nuts
oh God he didn't deploy military yeah he
let people ride different buildings
crazy I mean if you think about that
summer of 2020 and everything that
happened like all of the businesses that
were already suffering under the code
mandates that then suffered even more
and he did intervene it's hard not to
forget that that final year of his
presidency was really rough for him I
think he did do a lot of great in the
first three but is that enough to
balance out the final final year I'm I'm
also kind of just like I want to see
Trump finish finish off what he was what
he wants to do I want to see him just
have a crack at it I don't know if
that's meaningless like there's nothing
really behind the idea but there's like
an emotional part of me that's like we
just gotta get you know Trump's got to
go in and then finish what he started
whatever that was supposed to be what is
it what does he think I mean the foreign
policy stuff was huge that that to me is
is a massive component Shoring up our
borders he first thing he does get rid
of TPP he wants to bring jobs back to
America he wants to get rid of the car
stuff he wants to secure our borders
better working class jobs better
manufacturing getting NATO and our
allies to pay their fair share getting
our troops out of these foreign
countries all of that stuff sounds like
the right track the economy was booming
there are a lot of questions about
spending there's a lot of issues with
foreign policy I get all that but I I'm
like I don't know what I get with
DeSantis I see Florida I have a general
idea with Trump it's like kind of want
to see him just wrap that one up with a
nice nice little bow what do you guys
think about bringing back extremely
dirty industry to the United States
don't leave favor of it
we need to be developing in Alaska
we modern technology can address those
concerns if we build a factory 70 years
ago and we've been updating it a little
bit well it's no surprise at pollutes if
we build a modern version of that
Factory from the ground up we're going
to mitigate a lot of those issues so an
interesting thing happens with
technology with industrialization the
United States cellular data sucks
because we're the first to roll it out
we roll out what was it the Iden Network
might have been the first one and it's
like garbage
foreign country like Ukraine doesn't get
cell phones at all then we invent better
Technologies we end up with CDMA
Ukraine begins to install CDMA but
instead of getting Generation 1 tech
like we built they build third
generation Tech so I go to in the United
States this is way better 10 years ago
I'm using CDMA cell phones and getting
like 0.1.2 megabits I go to Ukraine same
cell phone two megabits well how is that
possible because they have a modernized
version of that new tech that was built
if we're going to bring back these
industries to the United States by
easing on environmental regulations yes
there's a risk of pollution however we
can set new leases for developing in
areas like Alaska which I believe is
being tremendously wasted I'm sure a lot
of alaskans would love to have the
development to improve their lives and
when we build these factories we build
these developments we can build them
with modern versions if they're not
technology which mitigates for a lot of
the pollution and helps you know
facilitate it away yeah we could rebuild
the railroads with graphene instead of
iron or whatever steel that warping
bending metal something that's stronger
because I may have a problem with
industrialization is the transportation
where they're not even on the metal
they're Gliding Over the metal super
cooled super conductor yeah no friction
so there's that called a red matter that
can be used for that it's a high
extremely awesome superconductor they
just invented that I I agree I think the
issue with um maglev is they have to be
in cities with high power you need
whereas if we're going across
Countryside you're a car or something
but yeah we can build better faster
trains and we can build better
infrastructure and build all these
things the reason that Donald Trump
wanted to ease environmental regulations
was to bring companies back from from
China what happens is and it's very
obvious the United States imposes
environmental regulations increasing the
cost for a business to operate they then
increase the taxes on that business they
then cut tariffs and so the company says
it's going to cost me 20 taxes and 20
percent more environmental regulations I
have to offset
or I can send my factory to China and
ship the product here for free with no
regulations no taxes that's exactly what
they do so when the Democrats got in
people are wondering like what did Joe
Biden do though so bad for the economy
well uh increase environmental
regulations increase corporate taxes and
decrease tariffs resulting in companies
fleeing the country and shipping the
products back stripping jobs away from
Americans and extracting the value from
our economy and destroying the country
we're watching it happen yeah it also
takes our supply chain and gives part of
it to the Chinese which is a very very
high vulnerability for the supply chain
yeah I take it a step further and say
just raising the cost of producing
energy in no way produces cleaner energy
and there's there's all sorts of
trade-offs like Thomas Massey was here
he'd point out all of the quote-unquote
dirty industry that's involved with
making clean energy and then there's the
whole question of world war three
um maybe we should actually produce more
oil and gas in this country and maybe
our Ally should as well so that we we
don't and in a nuclear winter because
that's that's dirty too have you ever
played civilization it's a great game
geopolitics if you're if you have a huge
Trade Network with your neighboring
country you've got eight trade routes
you're getting your iron from them
you're getting your horses from them
you've got most of your income from them
if they go to war with you it all goes
to zero you have nothing and then they
are they do because you've been getting
it from them now they have all no no
that's it it's the worst situation when
your trade partner stops or goes to war
with you kids in schools should be
forced to play this game I say forest
like it should be an assigned thing and
the kids would love it because it's an
educational tool yeah but anybody's ever
played civilization he'll do that not
I'm not even kidding yeah so here's an
example uh in one of my playthroughs of
civilization I had this very powerful
and big nation and then when we got to
the discovery of rate of uranium my
country had no uranium at all there was
none in my territory and so I had this
massive expansion and growth then when
we got to this technological level all
of a sudden the underdeveloped
neighboring country that stole my
technology with spies had tons of
uranium and started building nukes and
I'm like damn
they they have it in their borders I
what do I do
they're we're going to go to war and
they've got this stuff so what do you
have what do you do well I mean
hope you don't go to war and then you do
and then you're fighting and they have
uranium and you can't so you can't build
these weapons they can you got to go
seize that City that's got access to it
so you can build them and they can't
it's a it's an amazing video game it's
brilliant yeah it really it puts the
utilitarian aspect of War into Clear
View like if your opponent has a weapon
that will destroy you you have to take
that away from them I mean otherwise
they will win and it's a game of winning
and losing you know real life isn't
winning and losing it's about living
together so it's not about like Risk
with more factors yeah it's not all
about fighting you can win culturally
you can win uh religiously
diplomatically there's different ways to
unite the planet and win scientifically
you can launch a spacecraft first to
Alpha Centauri you can take over cities
through culture yeah so you can actually
have your cities produce music movies
social media and then what happens is
that culture expands your borders and
influence and if it starts pressing upon
another city with too much force
eventually the city will request to join
you and that it makes the other country
really angry and then they can threaten
war against you and you're like hey look
they came to us that's kind of like talk
about the culture well that's the
culture War you flip cities like in
France right now there's these there's
these riots and explosions and burning
then the cops are on the side of the
people like that's the culture flip so
that can happen with literally cities as
well that just happened the cops joined
the protest there's a bunch of cops
walking with the protesters the culture
wars I saw a picture of my crown with
like his he's like face palming because
it's been going on for months now or
something like that brutal widespread
rides across France
I mean he survived the no confidence
vote but the people do not like it right
like the legislature allowed his
stay in place but he has really upset
the people of France with his uh his
retirement plan issues I mean I think
this game sounds really fascinating and
I don't think I've ever played it before
but I do think that when we talk about
Tick Tock uh and we talk about kind of
the American Acceptance of what's going
on with Ukraine or our involvement in it
a lot of that has to do with long-form
cultural warfare that's been going on
for a long time I think America thinks
of itself as the leading exporter of
culture in the world and that's just not
true at this point and I think largely
that is because of the internet like
other countries can take some of our
culture but also maintain their own
right so we saw this there were a couple
times that uh you know there are movies
that China is rejecting that typically
they've let in or they are seeing their
own uh original content outperform
imported American movies and that's
because they are prioritizing their own
culture I think the way that we saw
people sort of readily adopt uh the the
Ukraine lag out of this understanding
that like we should be helping them is
sort of this idea that we are the Global
Citizens this cultural war that we have
put on our own people I don't know how
you feel about this
no uh well I I so I'm not a culture
Warrior but I I think that culture is
everything
and so I tend to be sort of uh Blue Sky
optimistic about
letting people free to figure this stuff
out and so I worry less about the fact
that China is manipulating us or that
Russia is manipulating us and that free
people have a natural ability to figure
stuff out do you think that
American like the youth in America is
truly free and I only ask in the context
of you know the algorithm on Tick Tock
we hear about it all the time and I I
sound vaguely afraid of Technology but
you know there is the idea that the
youth in America are being fed content
that is meant to psychologically disrupt
them right to encourage anxiety to push
other uh kind of you know negative uh
experiences and emotions so therefore
they are completely consumed by
basically collapsing in on themselves
while China's Chinese uh teens are being
encouraged to pursue stem and other
things like are you truly free if you
have this uh technological disrupter
coming through well you're you're still
free but like the the phenomenon of of
like a herd mentality and and most
people just sort of Following the Leader
is not a new thing and it's not caused
by technology and most of cultural
change and most of of cultural
development comes from those cultural
entrepreneurs that speak up and say you
know what let's do it a different way so
I still have confidence in those young
people that are thinking
because that's what defines culture it's
not just that the Mindless mob that that
shuffles forward like zombies because
that's always been there and social
media absolutely amplifies that tendency
but someone's going to step out and say
guys
over here this is what we need to really
care about and I think that's that's how
the the wisdom of crowds works most most
of the crowd does not practice wisdom
but somebody says guys we're going in
the wrong direction we got to go this
way and it always just works out let's
uh let's jump to this cultural story
this is a this is an interesting one we
have this uh tweet I saw this image from
icons women Hannah aaronsman says I have
decided to end my cycling career at my
last race at the recent UCI cyclocross
national championships in the elite
women's category I came in fourth place
flanked on either side by male writers
awarded third and fifth places my sister
and family sobbed as they watched a man
finish in front of me having witnessed
several physical interactions with them
throughout the race
so this is this is like the photo was
the woman crying as she's quitting
because she was denied the podium by a
male athlete there's another story where
another male has won I think like 15
races yeah like 15 to 15 or some
ridiculous number in New York right yeah
I just won one in New York and uh I feel
bad for this woman but I think she's
doing the right thing in quitting and I
think all of these women need to quit
and maybe make a new league maybe make
the female division or something it's a
great example of the leader that steps
out of the herd and says this is insane
we need to stop doing this and she's
going to pay an insane price she's
giving up her dream and her career to do
that but I but I think the tide is
turning I think the insanity people are
starting to say what are we doing here
well we have a story here from uh
timcast.com World Athletics Council bans
biological male athletes from from
competing against females officials say
the policy update is to protect the
Integrity of female Athletics so it's
starting to happen I mean that's that's
big huh yeah I mean especially this
issue I I ran track in high school so
it's a sport I care a lot about but
there are there was a group of um track
athletes in Connecticut that were some
of the first to file a lawsuit and say
you can't let male biologically male
athletes compete with us because it does
take away our right to compete in a
sport like you are flying in the face of
something that theoretically feminism
fought for and and those two males were
not undergoing hormone therapy or
anything like that they were just males
who were like I want to compete against
the females because I'm a woman they
said fine and they kept winning every
race and breaking records yeah and it's
especially like on the high school level
it means that you don't uh show up on
the rosters that college coaches get so
you miss out on scholarship
opportunities like if if uh you are an
elite athlete competing at that level
you can't expect a coach to look at the
list and say oh well you know these
these names all appear female to me so
why would I question this right and
especially if we're supposed to treat uh
biological men who had identify as women
the same way then you are literally
giving away spots on teams and
educational dollars to them when these
girls have trained for so long to get to
that place it I mean it seems like to me
it seems like common sense but I
understand our culture has created a
different narrative around this well I I
feel like uh you know Matt was saying
the insanity is starting to be pushed
back against I think we're starting to
win on this front so maybe that's a good
thing maybe the United States can
finally get its act together there was a
a couple big moments one was when
jenkuger of The Young Turks agreed with
Bernie Sanders saying we want equality
of opportunity not outcome that's like
okay welcome back to the mix and then we
have I think I have the Tweet right here
anna kasparian of The Young Turks
tweeted I'm a woman please don't ever
refer to me as a person with a uterus
birthing person or person who
menstruates how do people not realize
how degrading this is you can support
the transgender Community without doing
this ish and of course she got ripped to
shreds the left one after her and
started screaming at her and insulting
her they're calling them the young turfs
now inside of Young Turks but I'm like
well you know what if The Young Turks
are pushing back on the insanity
gradually I'll accept it I will take it
and maybe we're going to start winning
more ground in the culture War that's a
good thing man and talk about if this is
another one I think that there's really
no winning or losing it's about can we
co-exist the victory is can we all win
and when you see Anna went on Ben
Shapiro's show a month ago I didn't know
that and they had a great conversation
it's fascinating to talk about Medicare
for all I mean it's legit and then I
just saw Sam Cedar went on valuetainment
so it's like people that you would
consider from the left and the right are
coming together to talk I think a lot of
it's because of this this this banking
Fiasco you know the economy hitting its
Breaking Point people are like what
choice do I have at this point I think
there have probably always been people
who say like hey this is something that
we should not we should not pursue so
because it's one history histories month
I've been writing about anti-feminists
and I this week I published a profile of
uh Camille Paglia which I'm definitely
pronouncing her name wrong but she is an
academic at University of Arts in
Philadelphia and she gets this rep
reputation of being you're not even of
being the anti-feminist feminist she
said you know I was a feminist in the
1960s and we fought for our rights to be
free we fought so that we wouldn't have
to have curfews in college dorms we
could risk the right to be raped and
attacked on campus Because we wanted the
right to like take care of ourselves and
not be in the protection of men or
whatever else and one of the things that
she has gotten in trouble for in more
recent years is saying you know
you guys should pay attention to biology
you guys seem really interested in
science except for when it applies to
this issue and she says you know you
can't your biology says you can't just
suddenly decide you're a different
gender and this has ousted her from the
feminist Community I mean she still
identifies as a feminist but feminists
don't want her there even though she's
one of the most noted academics in this
ideology it's crazy she's the most legit
feminist out there and my wife and I
have this this fantastic argument and I
always lose arguments with my wife but I
consider myself a radical feminist and I
see the comments are going to freak out
here my wife considers herself an
anti-feminist because we both believe in
really strong women that have the right
to determine their own destiny and
that's what feminism used to be about
and you know my childhood intellectual
hero was a woman Ein Rand she turned me
on to a lot of these ideas and she was a
badass who fled uh the Soviet Union
after her father's business was stolen
when she was still a teenager and she
ended up in Hollywood as a scriptwriter
that's badass and that's my sort of
heroic view of what women can be in
modern feminism and all of this stuff
we're talking about it is so
anti-feminist in every single way and
and back to Anna for just a second
that's that's a heroic stand that she's
taking because she's taking on her own
audience her own woke audience is is
trying to destroy her and you know it's
one thing for for us to criticize that
my audience isn't going to get mad at me
if I criticize uh wokism but but she's
got to deal with that yeah
that's a hero The Young Turks probably
lost a lot of money by them coming out
and saying this yeah and I think it's a
good thing and I hope they lose more not
because I want them to suffer or because
I'm trying to be mean but because they
need to free themselves in the shackle
of this cult and if they no longer have
any incentive to try and please these
people and it seems like they're already
shaking that off maybe they'll stop
pushing a lot of that garbage yeah so
good for them I mean what are the odds
that she wants to jump ship anyways
right like if she's gonna take this
dance she must know that she's defend
yourself he is okay yeah outright
defending her and saying she's never
going to apologize and he agrees with
her so I I do think the main issue with
Young Turks is that they're duplicitous
you know I can respect her making the
statement but they make fake videos
about me and other people all the time
so it's not like I expect them to never
be good people or anything like that but
I'll get incredible credit is due yeah
we need to we need to make these gains
on the culture war and take what we can
get when we can get it so I don't know I
thought the young turfs was really funny
that is funny
I like it it's less offensive Than The
Young Turks like they named their
organization after the Armenian Genocide
it's crazy
I like your take about being an extreme
feminist I always say that my dad is the
most is the biggest feminist I know he's
constantly telling me I can do things
that I'm capable I don't like it it's
the worst uh no but I'm being serious I
feel like there are so many men
conservative men that I know who are
advocates for you know strong capable
women and they believe that women are
completely capable it's the victim
mentality that has crept into this
modern iteration of feminism that I just
can't get behind I don't understand why
it would be appealing to anyone I also
just hate giving up words that that are
packed with meaning and value and and we
always find ourselves like
um
attacking the word justice or attacking
the word democracy or attacking
attacking the word Community because
it's been co-opted to mean something
that it doesn't mean and I think we
should be feminists because we're
pro-women yeah just just to find what
you mean and don't let don't let the
bastards steal our language from us
that's it's we're in the fourth wave of
feminism the word but the word has
different meanings in every wave the
second wave of feminism is the one
you're talking about from this one I was
raised with my mom I was like as a very
young kid I asked my mom does feminism
mean that women are better than men she
said no feminism means that men and
women are equal and that was all I
needed after it changed my life I was
like okay I get it so right now it
didn't make sense but if you ask a trans
activist
they will use the phrase CIS woman
but they want you they say trans women
are women so just say woman
CIS women however are CIS women you see
what they're doing yeah they are they're
they are taking the the the normative
term woman applying to themselves and
then making CIS women the outlier the
other the reality is if you're a man and
you want to transition to a woman you
can be a trans woman and you're still a
man you never stop being a human you're
still a human like you don't end one to
become the other you become both
so it's very important to realize that
women are women and they can also be
trans men and women at the same time
well trans women is a subcategory of
male exactly so you're a man and a trans
woman or you can be a woman and a trans
man but you don't like lose one when you
try and like Transit you're still the
same you're still a human you never stop
being a man you never stop being a human
you're still even if you identify as a
shoe you're still a human but this is
like where the concept of dead naming
comes in right like if someone says you
know now that I have accepted this
identity and I I believe I'm supposed to
be like this you should never refer to
me and even reference I don't want to
see pictures of this person I was before
I mean they they do feel as though they
can completely leave behind you know
this this part of themselves they can
they can do whatever they want and I'll
do whatever I want but the whole like
this is who I was before like it's still
now you're still you you you are
different and you're still you like it
doesn't
you know it's I I don't know like it's
not like you you're no longer what you
were you're still you're still that and
more now so I
but but Tim's point is like uh we're not
giving up the word woman
that's our word we know what that means
that's our word you can't say it yeah
well no like says hat says there's
they're slurs if they're going to make
the argument that trans women are women
then I'll make the same argument and say
then you can't say CIS woman that's
that's a derogatory in the same way you
claim it is so your own logic negates
your right to do so that being said I
mean like trans women
defines something it is a biological
male who identifies as female
there you go end of story you can't then
say you are a woman well you're a trans
woman there's a qualifier for that
because you are different from woman
yeah you can't be a trans woman if
you're a woman you would you have to be
a man to be a trans woman yes
yeah and you have to be a woman to be a
trans man
so they're they're playing with
definitions I think for legal reasons
because if they can switch get the
culture to start arguing that woman
includes males it changes civil rights
law
and then you see these like guys beating
women in races and things like I
understand I want to project that future
because it looks like people are waking
up and kind of acknowledging how dirty
it is for a guy to be like I feel like a
woman and I'm gonna take your trophy
lady like what the in hell what
kind of world is that people get really
annoyed about it when it's uh when you
have college athletes who are like not
that particularly good and then they
come back and they said actually I
identify as as female and so they
outperform everyone else I mean we've
seen this time and time again I think
part of it is because they're basically
saying I realized that I could probably
beat you guys and I don't want to
downplay whatever psychological elements
that come into this kind of decision
making but you know it does seem crazy
that you would just say like I
I think I deserve this and I will
continue to compete as if I'm just as
entitled to this position as you are
when really I'm competing with
advantages that you could never have
I'm very grateful that this girl came
out and made that that statement what
was her name again did you have that uh
Hannah aaronsman I'd love to have her on
the show sometime Taylor Silverman spoke
out about this a long time ago and it
really improved her standing and career
as far as I can tell she seems really
happy about it and was really scared
about speaking up about it but she
wasn't happy that people yeah she works
here yeah she works with Tim Cass we uh
we've been trying to put a skate show
together for a long time but we need the
new facility to be to be built and it
got delayed for so long that we were
planning on having the show started like
seven months ago
but now the building's nearing
completion so we may actually get that
ball rolling and then we have some other
proscape orders in mind who are going to
co-host the show but I'm just like we've
gotta we've gotta we've got to provide
support to people who are doing the
right thing standing up and uh Taylor is
good people she's super nice you know
super chill and just said hey it's not
okay that like I would have got first
place and made more money but not being
taken away from me so we did this thing
where
I wrote her a check and we did like a
big fake check saying like here's the
difference here's what you would have
won and we paid that and then offered
her a job and said you know why don't
you host the skate show once we get it
going and then we'll get it going I
think one of the most important there's
several things that we need to do if
we're going to win a culture where one
is make culture that's why we've been
working on these projects with a video
game and development we've got the
coffee shop in development the new
facility is going to include a bunch of
new shows a Morning Show with a bunch of
ladies we're gonna do the skate show
we're gonna do poker with the boys poker
with the boys I am most excited about
that's going to be the best show ever
because uh during the members only show
the other night when we had Troy Nails
on Congressman someone suggested like
members of Congress need to do these
things like AOC did with playing Among
Us on Twitch and getting all these
viewers why don't you do that well I
don't think it makes sense for like you
know uh late 50s or 50 50s ish you know
member of Congress guy to be like
playing a video game with some kids but
you get a Matt Gates of Troy nails and
like a Lauren bobert playing a game of
poker with a bunch of people and they're
they're talking smack and that's the
kind of thing that's personable
relatable and culture building yeah so
that that's another big component the
other thing is
giving money to people who are doing
good things right James O'Keefe does
this when a whistleblower would come out
he'd be like we're going to give you a
job we're going to make sure that you do
not get punished for being a
whistleblower and I'm like I'm thinking
the same thing Taylor Silverman did the
right thing we want to do a skate show
we need to host perfect opportunity for
a good person who has good principles
and and the courage to speak up to be
given an opportunity so let's make sure
the people who are speaking up don't
have that fear where it's like this
woman Hannah aaronsman she's ending her
career her cycling career what does that
mean for her for her income what does it
mean for her future there needs to be
something for her now so we need to
figure out how to do that how can we
make sure that there are resources
available to people who want to stand up
and do the right thing they do not get
left destitute I mean especially in this
case I feel like she is officially in a
career but her career is also being
ended for her right if you're a
competitive athlete like this I mean
there must be a prize associated with
each level so if you can't place first
second or third then you are missing the
potentially large payout that you need
to fund the training and everything else
that goes into this career and the
sponsorships that go away I mean I can't
imagine that these brands are like oh
I'll sponsor number four the one who
consistently comes in fourth but it's
sort of you know a rigged game she's
being forced out of this this income
that she's built for herself which of
course as an athlete there's a there's a
clock on that anyways you can't
necessarily compete forever It's just
sad that this is happening why don't we
just have transgender divisions
why why is it that there was the Isaac
Hennig who who was biologically female
competing against women and then
transfers to the men's team and says now
I'm not winning as much oh so you so you
acknowledge this there's this lie among
the left where they're like there's no
advantage to being male in sports then
why are the where where are the females
competing against males there's like two
and they both acknowledge they don't do
as well duh why is it only ever males
competing against females because
anybody who's sane understands this and
the problem I see with this
if I'm going to go into a Committee
hearing and be like as as a member of
this committee I cast my vote to say
Obviously males will have physical
advantages over females and then the
other guys in across them goes no they
don't I vote against you and I'm like
okay we're this is not democracy this
makes no sense democracy does not work
we cannot function this way if you have
two people one's insane and one's saying
you get nothing
well we don't want a mixture of sin
insane we want same we want a sane
system but we have insane people voting
for insane things for insane reasons so
you build a Republic and you hope to
guard that people vote insane people I
guess if you get enough insane people
maybe they'll vote in an insane person
and they are somehow somehow but most of
the people in Congress are way more sane
than a lot of the crazy stuff I'm seeing
on the internet that's I don't see like
crazy I don't start blaming I just want
to see what happens with Gen Z right
like I I am so fascinated because
theoretically they are marginally more
conservative than Generations before
them but also 15 one in six uh identify
as lgbtq I guess
so they're kind of divided among
themselves it seems like they are
drifting in in tons of directions
although I feel like we talk about this
a little bit like there are things that
I think our generation feels differently
about like we there are a lot of
Millennials who feel more socially
liberal they take a fiscal conservative
approach like they are not as rigid in
their political stances the generations
before them uh I I think gen Z is going
to be hard to predict in that sense
because we feel like someone will stand
like you're saying before someone will
come to the service and say like hey
let's not do this anymore but I feel
like there are enough components of that
generation that believe really really
intensely in the dogma of what they're
being taught young people are always up
for grabs they're always trying to
figure out who they are and where they
belong and it's not everybody's going to
take the lead in figuring it out and
it's going to be someone that they
respect from their generation that steps
out and maybe they maybe they quit
cycling because of something insane and
that becomes a defining moment in in
their sort of figuring out where they
belong and I just have a lot of
confidence in people and I I think I
love it I love the positivity I don't I
don't think we're all crazy
um we're not the people you see on
Twitter it's going to be okay you have a
much too high opinion about members of
Congress I must say you got to bring
that in maybe I'm learning to love them
because I've been spending time with
them and hanging out be careful yeah
yeah but he's talking about like two
members yeah I keep talking about Matt I
love you Matt
um and I understand it's kind of like a
club like you wanna I I like I don't
like alliances I don't like clicks and
like I feel like maybe when you get into
Congress first of all it's way too big
it's not working right it was made for
like 80 people to be our Representatives
there's 430 and they don't even know
each other it's disturbing like you walk
around the halls of Congress I won't see
95 of the con of the people or their
offices because they're all over
everywhere I never saw him hanging out
it's like a big deal to get five
Republicans together uh so that's a big
problem problem with Congress is it is
way too big they need to know each other
the other problem is
congressional districts keep getting
denser and denser set one at 775 000
people for one rep good luck getting
represented yeah we need a severe
overhaul the way we govern I don't want
to like rip the government apart but it
will change we need to adapt there is
one alternative I mean maybe the answer
is there needs to be less people and we
can maybe Implement programs to
encourage them and not to have children
and sickeningly that would be nervous
that would be one one way to get there I
think but yeah Bill Gates huh I think if
people could represent themselves a
little easier because the whole purpose
of sending a representative was so that
they could represent you more
effectively than you could represent
yourself but now with the internet you
have an opportunity to throw up an
internet video and that's full
representation of who I am wouldn't that
be a step wouldn't a step in that
direction just be returning more power
to the states right because then you're
being represented on a smaller level I
mean right now you would Tim is totally
right like for each member of Congress
really there's a huge number of people
they're representing in the U.S if you
were to give them equal representation
on a federal level you'd make Congress
even bigger I think like 8 000 people it
would be insane it wouldn't it would be
ridiculous
or hear me out crazy talk what if we let
people make more decisions for
themselves is that is that insane but uh
yes how would that work right so when we
have woke people who are like
filibustering this woman in in Nebraska
demanding demanding the the the the the
legal right to castrate children it's
like okay
how far we want to go with this and how
far does her disease making Powers go in
this country are we talking about she
can only affect her local jurisdiction
then the question is if I live in West
Virginia and I hear that in Ohio
but to the hundreds to the thousands
they're giving young girls mastectomies
and sterilizing them do we just go well
you know I don't know that's Ohio we're
not going to get involved in that or do
we say like hey we got to stop that so
that like um I always lean towards
making sure that that parents have more
rights and and I when I see school
districts which are government entities
when I see State politics or local
politics intervene in that relationship
where a lot of this stuff is coming from
I think that's the cancer that needs to
be wiped out and I think I think parents
have to have that responsibility I'm not
saying that parents will get it right
every time last night's show proved that
but I trust parents more than
politicians and I absolutely trust
parents more than these these interest
groups that that are feeding off of this
system there's huge financial benefits
to to all of these therapies and drugs
and treatments
that's all intertwined with government
and if we're going to unwind that we
have to shift power back to parents
power back to people about power back to
communities to to judge parents who
aren't doing a good job what but who
gets to Define what a good job is right
so the challenge is
there is there's two arguments the left
argument is not cutting off the child's
testicles is genocide that's what this
woman said outright she said it is
genocide
they genuinely believe or at least they
presume to believe that they're saving
children's lives
well by that argument they're preventing
a genocide
you're going to have a community of
people be like we're all here in
agreement printing genocide is bad
therefore we're going to sterilize a
bunch of kids I I mean I think that view
is insane and I think that parents would
reject it
but we're watching in California the
embracing of it in Mass
they're they're codifying it in law in I
think Washington a child can get
codifying that's that's my point but in
in washing I think it's Washington a
child can get gender affirming surgery
and medical intervention without
parental consent they can go to a doctor
and just get it done by law by law what
if you gave
first of all that is the opposite of
what I'm talking about what if you gave
parents the rights to it shouldn't even
be a right like parents are the the
governing body of their children did you
see the video of jazz Jennings we talked
about the other day yeah I listened to
less what about parents like that do we
give them the right
I
I think you have to err on the side of
of even like
uh not in that specific case I think
that should be I think you should
intervene because that's that's violence
against a person that would require
State Powers determining morality to
intervene and stop parents who are doing
things we deem bad or or community stand
like this community standards still
protect life and property this is where
you know don't don't hurt people and
don't take their stuff but their
argument is they're not so the challenge
the challenge is
the system we have now is supposed to
have a federal government which protects
rights and if we have a shared and
cohesive morality you do not allow a
parent to do to Jazz what that woman is
doing to that that poor poor human being
for those who are not familiar with the
story it's a viral clip
of jazz Jennings mother saying she wakes
Jazz up in the middle of the night grabs
a dilator lubricates it and says stick
this in or I will I mean that's the most
horrible it's horrifying and then she
even says if she goes up to college and
doesn't do this I'll ring her neck and
it's just like
jeez
but among that Community they believe
they're in the right I believe the state
should stop these insane people from
from committing what I believe I mean
that look if an adult human being makes
a decision to get surgeries and do
whatever I'm like okay well you know
there's that's that's your life right
you want to look like a cat and get
implants in your face but this is this
is this child's been in my view tortured
their whole life they're depressed
they're morbidly obese they're clearly
not wanting to carry on with this this
is where I think the state needs to come
in and save this person because it is on
television a woman saying if you don't
Jam this in your wound I will do it and
it's like at what point is this physical
abuse and psychological abuse if you
gave these people Reigns of their own
Community they would keep doing things
like this they were I mean there were
General mutilations going on in Dearborn
Michigan we've talked about that was
years ago so I think there's a that's
that's a challenge for me with
libertarianism
where you make this argument that
parents have the final say in the health
care of their children and it's like
okay well this lady thinks Health Care
is cutting off her daughter's tits like
I disagree with that I'm like well of
course we all agree that's wrong yeah
well they don't and if we send in
federal authorities to stop them they'll
scream Civil War yeah so that's why I'm
like I don't know what the what the
solution is it's a dilemma because
um some parents are going to get it
horribly wrong and and my question is if
we say that the state is in charge of
protecting children
what if the crazies get to write the
laws that start mandating these kinds of
things they're doing that this is a
conversation that I
got really interested in Liberty
internism it was when I was interested
in I thought I was going to go into
foster care and like work on adoption
law because there are all times that we
agree there are children who are in
incredibly dangerous situations with
parents who are not fit to take care of
them and what you do because if you
believe in limited to no government how
do you also protect these children and
it was some this Crux that I never got a
clear answer on I hate to say that
because again with with transgenderism
it's a little bit different because
people feel as though they are doing
what's right as opposed to like yeah you
know more obvious we can all agree this
is a complete and total abuse uh but
what you do make the awards of the state
yeah I mean before before there was a
welfare state there were churches and
other social institutions that emerged
to and hopefully to help solve these
problems but there there is absolutely
no perfect solution to a broken family I
know it's terrible because the thing is
like you want to believe that a
community organization whether it's run
by just the people of that Community or
the religious group could also protect
them but ultimately we know that's not
always the case and it just feels like
especially when you talk about young
children it's such a Gamble and there's
not a lot of time you can't really say
oh we'll try it with something with this
batch and then we'll see if we get it
right the next time because you
obviously I just think that you're
always better off with with local peer
pressure and Community institutions
making sure the children are okay the
further away you get from that child all
the way up to Washington DC or you know
God help us some some Global thing
that's going to emerge they don't give a
damn about that kid what about marketing
like corporations because television is
local it's in your house but obviously
like the corporate headquarters is could
be in Kansas or wherever so what are
your like I mean a corporation can't
make you do what they want you to do
unless they happen to be a
pharmaceutical company that cuts a deal
with the government to force you to take
their product or like show a kid
cartoons of a guy eating sugar when
they're one and then I guess it's up to
the parent not to put the kid in front
of the television to get indoctrinated
by the corporation yeah to buy their
product or or stop the food industrial
complex from hijacking the government
nutrition standards again I'll always go
back to some corruption where where big
corporations get in bed with big
business they buy access and they force
you to do things that you didn't want to
do obesity didn't come from nowhere it
came from from those those corporations
hijacking that government process we're
going to go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it because word of mouth is one of
the most powerful things you can do to
help and go to timcast.com become a
member by clicking join us then join our
Discord server and if you get into the
VIP chat you can submit questions for
our call-in segment which happens in the
members only portion at around 10 10 pm
the uncensored show will go live hang
out it'll be a lot of fun and then we'll
take a handful of callers around 10 30
who actually can ask us questions and
our guest questions it was really really
amazing the past couple of nights we're
looking forward to it let's see what we
got Christina H says band camp haha
that's right band camp band us and uh
five times August and Bryson gray
because they're cultists
and they just never respond like this is
the craziest thing that even send you
like uh you know oh you violated our
term service because we just said
nothing they said because we didn't
break any rules they're just the cult is
taking over these institutions
so be it so be it we're going to use
Alternatives maybe we'll build our own
uh head over to
trashouserecords.com and pre-order the
song which go live goes live tonight at
midnight
so I'm really excited about that you
know in March of 2022 band camp was
acquired by epic games so it's actually
epic games that banned you really um
epic games but bandcamp 20. and epic
games is woken crazy almost yeah
apparently I don't know the cult is
expanding they are at war with you they
are gathering resources they are buying
things up
all right
all right what do we got here Bullseye
Ben says hey Tim and crew looks like our
YouTube overlords are after y'all again
keep up the great work yeah it often
seems that's the case wow guess who owns
40 of
epic games 10 cent wow
a YouTuber called uh Moon actually who
does a video about the ownership of a
lot of these major corporations that
it's actually owned by tencent he did a
whole video on tencent if you guys want
to go watch it it's uh he's a good
YouTuber yeah anyways that explains it
we got banned from Tick Tock as well for
no reason yeah 10 cent yep
yeah see that's why I'm saying I think
China's doing a lot of this stuff it's
intentional here we are being like go
America we got to push back and then we
get banned on these platforms they they
are fighting a culture War man
and you got people like Biden who are in
on it yeah
uh Kellen said epic games is fortnite
for everybody by the way it's uh just if
you don't know what it is epic games is
fortnite so oh wow Noah yalverton says
Tim won't read this but I just wanted to
say I agree with him that the terms left
and right don't work anymore but I think
it's because people can't agree on what
left-wing and right wing is
it doesn't matter what they agree on
what it is it matters what it is and the
left and the right are tribal team names
that's it it doesn't mean anything about
your policies it just means which team
are you on
so when people are like liberal and left
it's like well all that really means is
team name I I think we should call them
like the screeching weasels and we can
be the the freedom faction
I love it that's good the reading
weasels the ringing weasels It's like
because like are they left economically
some of them maybe
are they like I mean like is is the
Lincoln project left you know what I
mean like they are of that same faction
but no
I don't know what they are never Trumper
they're authoritarian
yeah I think that's the dividing line
authoritarian or not
yeah collectivist cultist yeah
all right
ham hock says Tim I spent 10 years of
promoter Booker and talent buyer in my
region put on lots of concerts and even
some small festivals would love to be a
part of trash house any use for someone
like me probably but I don't know if
we're at that level yet
so we'll we'll see when we get there
I want trashhouse record merch we have
something yeah Carter was showing you
today and yeah great where do you get it
uh I don't know yet I don't know what do
you want I don't know if it's if it's
when you think about wearing something
like what is your first thought well I
like like big oversized t-shirts and
then Carter and I were talking about
like tie-dyeing them or doing different
stuff so they're like more custom so
Amos Moses says how far in is Hannah
Claire in the Fast and Furious
few reverse sorry fast and fewer verse
I'm uh I'm halfway through and I like so
like four or five I'm on five and I've
watched like several of them back to
back and then just burned out uh but I
I'm supposed sorry I know that's sin in
this room uh I'm supposed to get to nine
or ten before the next movie comes out
oh the next one should be electric
vehicles
I was wondering like are there gonna be
Teslas in it or it's going back to its
roots they went completely in the wrong
direction I'm really disappointed
because they had the last one was
Charlize Theron and like you know it's
the submarine and going to outer space
and all that stuff and now it's like a
street race it's like okay I guess are
you a fast and furious guy oh yeah I
haven't seen the new one though which
one is your favorite new one is in 10
that just came out or that that's not
that's not yet no we saw the last one
right when that outer space pretty cool
yeah
the the space one the space one what do
you think is the best one I don't know
they're all great and they got John Cena
in it now I just love the when the
family gets together at the end that's
the best part yeah so whenever I like
mention I have to like do this challenge
for crisis people are like it's all
about the family and I I love that as an
idea I just don't want to watch the rest
of the movie DC has one of the best
established universes in literature in
in fiction Batman Superman Green Lantern
all of these great story arcs the the
Justice Lords Arc I love it when
Superman becomes evil and becomes a
dictator and takes over the planet
there's a couple versions of it one is
like the Joker drugs him and he kills
Lois or something like that and then
Superman is like if only you know like
you let me kill him or whatever and then
he goes nuts and then he just starts
killing all of like there's great story
arcs and they couldn't make a movie
series they couldn't do it it was all
garbage then you get some old 2000s
movie about street racing and they've
turned it into the Avengers you know
what they deserve it they deserve it I
want to see Dominic argument I get that
I just like I guess I'm not enough of a
car person to appreciate it but it's not
about cars sorry I don't think about
cars I went outer space sorry I forgot
it's about family did it start off as
about cars though they're like I mean
it's like a central theme right they're
street racing and then they're like
stealing cars yeah the first couple was
about street racing they talk about like
engines but now they're PCS I'm still in
that part of this where it is it is like
there's stuff going on but it's largely
about the car chase scenes like that
you've got the transition into the
second half was the rock there yet
because then what happens is they get
they get tapped as like a crack team of
you know special agents to get the job
done and then you know the rock is like
we need your help and then you know then
you got uh Shaw who's like this bad guy
Jason Statham but then he becomes a good
guy or whatever and then his sister or
something and Charlie's Thrones like
they're getting all these celebrities in
it it's like better than the than the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I want
transformer crossover or superpowers I
just think that like one blonde guy and
that girl should just get married by now
like that's what's bothering me
they need to commit
Ghostface says Ian rolled a negative one
with that take on Obama which one when
you were like Obama should be allowed to
murder children because he was oh God I
just don't want to start persecuting and
and arresting former presidents I think
you mentioned that earlier too Matt it
just starts a cycle of yeah but crap I
think the cycle is getting worse because
we don't do it they have no fear they're
like when I get in I can do whatever I
want get away with it and like they're
going after Trump because he he's
accused of paying a woman not to talk
about having sex that's it
by the way it shouldn't be a president
it should be freaking Congress which has
the responsibility of declaring war and
has the responsibility for holding the
executive branch in check it should be
done that way but they will never do it
and Ian that one gamer says Anwar was
killed September 30th 2011. Abdul Rahman
was killed October 14 2011. Anwar was
already dead for almost a month wow so
it wasn't even sending in stat a message
no it was just killing the family yeah I
appreciate the super chat with the
negative one because it's a it's a hard
thing to talk about like whether a
president should have the ability to
just drone strike random people around
the around the earth that's kind of yep
Tony Ty says hey Tim I'm really feeling
the members segment after IRL especially
with the call-in questions I was
wondering if you all could go a little
bit longer or maybe take calls off the
bat
um we actually have been going longer
they've been going about 10 minutes
longer with the Collins so we've been
splitting 20 SEC 20 minutes of
uncensored uh show 20 minutes of of talk
I think it's a good balance there's a
lot of people who just want the the
cussing and the jokes and the serious
topics and then I think a lot of people
are really big into the Collins I think
the Collins may be the best value that
we can bring to you guys as members
I think that takes the members only
segment to a whole new level of of
community building of value uh
opportunity and all that I'm really
excited for it and again Ian's idea a
very good idea oh my gosh I love it we
could I mean we could technically have a
call going the entire night and just
because we go off and start riffing
while you're on there there's a lag it's
for the people who are listening it's
like it's hard to talk back and forth oh
yeah
well we got to figure that out we
because we like radio shows have calling
producers who will be like hey you're on
now go whereas we don't so what happens
is when someone calls in they don't know
when to talk because the show has a
delay right plus we're on we're going
through the internet they're using a
phone network so it's a lot easier for
them
all right OMG puppy says white
phosphorus and depleted uranium are both
war crimes done by nato in Belgrade and
Iraq even NATO troops in Serbia got
cancer from the uranium dust now Britain
sending depleted uranium to Ukraine yeah
we're heading that that way baby it's
gonna get bad
Pat Meadow says Obama executed an
American citizen who was a minor
that he did
yep
Barack Obama vote for me for Bob kids
gotta blow them up too many of them are
you auditioning for Freedom tunes right
now no that actually was Sheamus's joke
you're higher gotta blow him up too many
of them
Sheamus never made that cartoon though
he's got to do it Sheamus Barack where
is he at Shameless get over here yeah I
know he's like we keep telling him to
come and then he's just like me he's
like I don't want to come the weather's
nice now Sheamus you can come back
bipase says Tim you're you're wanding
the president to be treated like every
other citizen that sounds very
libertarian are you and Ian open to
supporting libertarianism if so why
haven't you I'd like your thoughts uh
the music caucus guys are great we we
we're we've been talking all day about
Dave Smith
um I would love to see I'm I'm he's
gonna do you know if he's gonna announce
he's running or whatever I'm waiting uh
you know I don't wanna there's there's
actually legal reasons not to right I
have no idea if he's going to run or not
but once you announce then you have to
raise hard dollars and it's a nightmare
Michael malice press secretary I'm so
excited huge advocate of libertarianism
in general I get concerned about it as a
political party because I find
interventionism is valuable a lot of
times a lot of times this whole like
hands-off if we ignore it it'll go away
problem the kind of thing I don't I
don't get down with I am speaking May
13th at the take with the take human
actiontour.com uh it's a the mises
caucus I believe this mises caucus is
putting it on and that's in Oakland and
I think we uh I would love to I'm not
sure what the deal is but do some kind
of debate slash Forum when the
libertarian party has like announced is
there in full swing I'm assuming it's
going to be Dave Smith we don't know
because he hasn't announcer or whatever
it may be Dave Smith with maj2ure as VP
which is just it's amazing and Michael
Mouse is a press secretary I just would
love to do a sit-down Big Show get an
audience to come in get a big venue and
do something maybe set up some kind of
debate or or something I think it'd be
fantastic
how do you guys feel about Justin Amash
because he there's still some question
about whether or not he runs I don't
know I don't know much about him I've
heard good things but uh
I think it has like a I'm pretty sure
like a bad track record during the Trump
Administration but I have to look into
it because I'm willing to to review
these things it's been a really long
time I haven't followed too much I've
had a bunch of people because he
switched it from Republican to
libertarian yeah so I've had libertarian
people tell me there's actually good and
to take a look but the only thing I
really remember from his tenure was that
he was like never Trumper like just like
and that was his bed oh the Republican
party is bad in Trump so I quit and it's
like well now look where we are that's
real great leadership
but I like Dave Smith and Dave Smith's
been you know against Trump for a long
time but I can respect someone who's got
the position so I'm you know I'm willing
to take a look into amash's I think just
arguments was one of the first uh to
adopt Minds when we built the website he
was like on it early I think so he was
in something very early where I realized
he was like red pilled and awake as to
what was going on like in 2011 or 2013
or something I'd love to interview him
and talk to him
it'd be interesting to have on and he
was absolutely
um anti-trump as a member of Congress
but he has a long career before that so
if that one thing is a deal killer for
you it's worth looking at what he's
willing to do yeah it's not you know
like Dave Smith Rags on Trump all the
time and I think Dave Smith is great you
know I mean like Luke Rags on Trump all
the time I I don't care people are mad
about Trump I just care that they have
real arguments behind why they're mad
about Trump and so Dave and we had to
talk the discussion about foreign policy
and stuff and he's right about a lot of
it now I can respect that absolutely I
just have a slightly different opinion
like if we got a leftist to come in here
like we're having Destiny on the show
next week and I'm a big fan I think he's
a good dude I disagree with him on stuff
and I think he's good at what he does he
makes good arguments but I think you
know I think he's good at arguing he's
good at debating
um I disagree and I think what a lot of
people don't understand is like if he
comes in here and he's like well don't
you think X Y and Z about transgender
surgeries and I'll be like I don't and
I'll be like well what about this then
well I guess we just disagree on that
that's fine we're like we're allowed to
disagree as long as you have an argument
and reasoning behind it like I'll argue
with you
and if you say something like deep
within my soul I personally feel
abortion should be legal I'll be like
well how do you argue there's no
argument someone just says I feel like
based on my morals and and stuff it's
like well okay yeah I'd rather than
trying to come out as a Victor in the
debate the debate itself is the victory
in my opinion the conversation the
pleasant you know that's that's the key
yeah like the end result is you know
like we had a lot on the show and he was
talking about why he's in favor of
intervention and stuff he's saying
because we don't want a multi-polar
world we want the US to be on top so
that it prevents war and you know it in
these horrible things so the US doing
this I don't want to you know overstate
what he was saying because I want to put
wrong words in his mouth but I'm like I
got mad like I was yelling at him I was
pissed off I was like this is ridiculous
like the foreign policy of this country
but um you know in the end like he's
been in the show several times he
reports for us on the ground he's
allowed to have that opinion and he has
reasons behind them he's explained them
in great detail and I've argued with him
and I got really angry but like that's
fine well you want the diversity of
thought like if he is reasonable and
well informed even if you don't agree
with him it's better to have him talking
oh you just have people saying like oh
yeah I agree with you you're such a
neocon I know he's a Bolton bro he's a
Bolton bro with his mustache yeah I know
what he's saying I hear you yeah no one
else does
yeah he's a Bolton bro you got the
mustache and oh my gosh his mustache is
off the chair sir do you want to defend
mustaches we came up with that elod you
know we came up with that but whatever
Bros
it wasn't even really like serious I'm
sorry you also have a mustache Matt are
you are you in favor of John Bolton I'm
not team Bolton
every man in this room has a mustache
I'm reporting live from Bolton bro
headquarter I mean the only reason yeah
but he's got out Bolton is so awesome
everything else is morally repugnant do
you think he smokes pipes it's a little
brown
he just sort of looks like a walrus to
me like he's like
what I expected Let's uh
Marvin Carlson says depleted uranium is
toxic mostly has a heavy metal-like
cadmium tungsten can also be used
instead of depleted uranium uranium is
easier to machine and less expensive
than tungsten we use depleted uranium
nose weights in 727s wow interesting
infernal Saxon says depleted uranium has
a self-sharpening property yeah and when
it it's searing hot so when it
penetrates the tank it ignites gases
inside and then causes it to become an
Inferno
yep
all right Mike Gibson says I was in the
Army signal Corps in the 90s outstanding
orders if we had to abandon our
equipment namely two grenades in the
switch Bernal documentation someone
ordered the troops to leave that
equipment intact whoa that's Yeah man so
in the switch I imagine that means like
in a vulnerable position within the tank
or what in the in the thing I don't know
what that term means but you definitely
use two grenades to blow it up make sure
they can't be used again I've also heard
they use thermite which is a military
and grade
um incendiary that you can use to melt
steel beams Jeffy Jeffrey grajik says
Ian is the modern day diogenes he
practiced being ridiculed by walking
backwards into a theater exit While
others were exiting keep asking the hard
questions regardless of what others say
about you that's awesome he's diogenes
the cynic is that who it is yeah a Greek
philosopher one of the founders of
cynicism I like it yeah I um humiliated
myself on purpose I didn't realize
that's what I was doing but after it
started to happen I realized it kind of
gave me strength of character
cleft the misfit says how the hell can
you say DeSantis is weak when he
Smackdown Biden fauci Disney teachers
unions and the Florida GOP establishment
taking near king-like control of the
state we need Luke back to set you
straight to him I will explain because
I've already pointed out policy wise he
hits the nail on that with the hammer
but in terms of his his character his
personality that's what I'm talking
about Trump didn't have the policy like
get rid of fauci don't do the lockdowns
policy fail but he has the screw you you
can't tell me what to do he had good
policy like securing our borders
bringing jobs back and foreign policy
was Exquisite I don't necessarily know
what the status will do on foreign
policy there are fears that he might go
neocon I don't know if that's fair to
say because we just don't know
my point is this Ron is getting it done
on paper but then when he's standing in
front of the cat in the cameras you know
Milo yiannopoulos put it well I don't
know if you saw his comment he said he
has the Charisma of something moist like
when you're reaching for something and
accidentally touch a wet sponge like it
was very well put is funny like DeSantis
doesn't have the same kind of Gravitas
As Trump that's what I'm saying the
strength of character of personality I
think policy wise he's getting it done
perfectly
so that's why I'm saying like what do we
need more of you know
all right where are we at
convincing reality says not everything
everyone does revolves around Trump
that's blinkered DeSantis has actually
made Moves In His State hasn't declared
himself for the presidency and he isn't
and he isn't Trump's campaign manager
yeah I know I like sandus you know we'll
see what happens
if he ends up winning I'll vote for him
Sparky says DeSantis just changed his
mind and Piers Morgan and is now
pro-ukraine War I saw that too you see
that's what we're worried about what did
he say why he was broken you want to
look it up because he was saying like we
shouldn't be involved and the media
attacked him for it and then he came
back he's like oh they're
misinterpreting what I'm saying or
something like that
Michelle Corley says descent is sold out
to rhinos he has ruined his career
president Trump is the one
not like Trump
hey look what are we at for is Trump
then we had eight years of DeSantis
maybe it just seems impractical that we
get three consecutive Republican
attorneys for sure but like I said I
don't think Trump
will run again after this you have to
take age into account if you think
potentially he's good maybe this is his
term and just answers to the Future he's
still really young Sparky says DeSantis
was anti-ukraine war on Tucker's
questionnaire but just changed to
pro-ukraine war on Piers Morgan what I'm
reading about is he referred to it as a
territorial dispute uh and then now he's
maybe walking that that he's walking
back that characterization so in the
beginning it sounds like he he saw it
kind of like I do which is that the
Russian Federation is attempting to
colonize Crimea and take roads into
Sebastopol the donbass because they want
that trade port in the Mediterranean
territorial it's not a genocide none of
this like we're going to kill those
people kind of thing they want they want
trade that's what it looks like but uh
maybe he's walked that back Raymond g
Stanley Jr says it's now or we're all
dead I can't help but agree with that
statement the downward spiral is real
and it's here damn it Ian decisions
decisions yeah dog but don't I do not
like using fear as a motivation it's not
like do it or else use this because that
one sucks I don't like that crap but it
it is a desperate and we need to work
together fast and accurately now Tyler
Bratton says due to federal employee
protections the president did not have
the power to fire fauci
uh who do we have on we had someone said
that wasn't true uh I think it was Matt
Gates actually someone said that you you
don't fire him you isolate and then a
month later they're gone it's like you
can fire them it can be done yeah like
it was it was Gates
yeah like you can you can take any
federal federal employee and then
completely isolate them from every
position and then within a month they're
terminated you could certainly
marginalize them and yeah part of the
problem is that we gave them the
microphone and it was Fouch the fouchy
show oh wait when Trump's standing
behind him like looking you know yeah I
don't know what Trump was thinking or
maybe he wasn't at all
Addison Miller says I live in Alaska and
we've been fighting for years to expand
development the problem is most of the
land is owned by the fed or is a
national park
I think we got to invade and occupy
Alaska that was a Daniel Turner and Jack
besobic talked about that occupy Alaska
it's like it's American territory it's
massive it's the third the size of the
United States and we're just not doing
anything with it like there's tons of
opportunity up there I keep thinking
about fusion and I wanted to ask you
about it Matt because you've talked a
lot about energy Independence and it's a
little bit off topic we only have a few
minutes left but do you think it's like
a path that we should head towards is
too dangerous for people to have that
um I don't know but I would love to have
an environment where that sort of
entrepreneurial Innovation was allowed
to happen
and and let science and entrepreneurs
figure that stuff out maybe Elon can
figure it out drag Mac says Tim I'm
still in the Peewee membership level and
want to upgrade without canceling and
resubscribing please take my money
um
yes uh we I think I think the issue is
that we have instructions on how to do
that in the Discord
so I'll we'll make sure that's in the
the Standard Lounge for any member to to
hang out to see the the pin instructions
let's make sure we can do that so
um here's what we're doing we're doing
two things with that
because I mentioned like the purpose of
the 25 level to get access to the VIP
room or six months is because we don't
want to make people spend more money to
get access but we also need a way to
control for Bad actors who are going to
try and come in and screw things up and
get us banned and that's a reality no
matter what we do but for the voice chat
we have to be a bit more strict but what
we're going to do is we're going to
create what we're calling I guess like
the silver Lounge which is if you pay 25
bucks not only do you get access to the
VIP chat room for Collins but you will
get a special 25 level because otherwise
it's just like what are you really
getting for the money other than you
know and then after six months you can
reduce your membership now that you're
you know you've passed that gate or
whatever
then with the elite club this is the
more costly Social Club element we're
building out it's a hundred bucks a
month for this room but we're giving
people access to testing out apps and
games early access to the stuff we're
working on so you're basically like in
the club so when we are like working on
song stuff like we'll maybe we'll like
here's a part of a new song we're
working on you'll get direct access to
all the internal stuff we're working on
like top secret stuff and that one is a
combination of we want to build like a
social club and a physical space that
comes to the coffee shop we're building
and we also uh need to be able to trust
a certain level of trust that like hey
if we share with you like a something
you don't you know leak it or whatever
like here's a new song we're working on
also it's like ends up on the Internet
or whatever yeah because tonight I want
to play uh Bright Eyes on the after show
but it's just a little premature and
it's coming out at midnight
we'll play it for the elite Discord
we'll give we'll we'll put it in there
somehow or something the elite members
will get to listen to the song tonight
all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this Channel and become a member by
going to timcast.com clicking join us
getting on the Discord and then we're
going to have that members only
uncensored show coming up in about 10
minutes where we will take your calls
should be a lot of fun you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me personally at timcast and
um what else I need to say is that is
that everything oh yeah
trashouserecords.com prior to the song
it's coming out at midnight and so we
need to do a big push all next week
because we're going to try and get on
Billboard again four four in a row maybe
we don't but the last three songs have
all got on billboards or we're three for
three it'll be awesome for four for four
and keep rubbing their faces in it
because they they when we when when we
send out emails being like hey new song
was released we actually got some of
these corporate press Outlets saying Fu
like literally like screw you f off so
we'll see uh Matt you want to shout
anything out sure I'm going to shout out
my friend Matt battagli who's our
executive producer he has a new book out
a comic book house on fire it's a
dystopian story about this unbelievable
world where the government tells you
that you can't leave your neighborhood
that they make it very difficult to find
uh the medicine that your wife needs and
and otherwise living in this
unbelievable dystopian future that
sounds a lot like America today
and you can find this at your favorite
shop and you can also find this on the
big guys like Amazon go to
freethepeople.org if you want to check
out our videos and we also have some
cool merch there as well
right on I'm Hannah clear brimwell I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should go to
uh you should follow at timcast news on
Instagram and Twitter it's great you can
see a lot of work from our journalists
all of it really and including a review
of house on fire by Chris Bertman who is
an awesome member of our news team so go
there follow them if you want to follow
me personally you can find me on
Instagram at hannah.b and on Twitter at
HC bromwell thanks so much Chris Bertman
also an excellent actor by the way nice
job Chris on the cast Castle I like your
work Matt always a pleasure man great
stuff house on fire check it out and I
want to adjust this in from Carter Banks
if you guys want to get merch tonight
trash House Records it is
trashouserecords dot Creator Dash
spring.com and that's trashaus
records.creator.spring.com you can
rewind the video if you need the link
and we're definitely getting to the
point now where we want to expand into
other artists doing more music than just
like the four songs we put out we've put
out this is our third song put out
through trash house will the people was
put out a couple of years ago those
first three songs will the people and
the two we put out did really well in
billboard hopefully this next one does
with your help but then we can actually
start finding more music and uh you know
yeah Landon Starbuck last night played
some of her music for us is incredible
her voice is amazing it was beautiful so
villain culture we're gonna get it we
will do that and we will do that tonight
at timcast.com see you then
yeah uh
join uh the website
video or video chat us like uh what is
called like phone in yeah phone in phone
in yeah phone in uh I'll see you there
bye all right everybody we will see you
all at timcast.com in about 10 or seven
or so minutes you'll be on the front
page you'll see it uncensored after show
click it it'll be live and if you're in
the Discord we will take some of your
calls thanks for hanging out we'll see
y'all there